हेलो
एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू
ऑल तो सबसे पहले मुझे बता द दीजिए आम आई
एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर ओके गुड तो दो मिनट वेट करते
हैं बाकी स्टूडेंट्स को जवाइन होने का फिर
हमारे सेशन को कंटिन्यू करेंगे
आप अपने साइड से वॉल्यूम बढ़ाइए मेरे साइड
से वॉल्यूम कम नहीं है फुल वॉल्यूम है और
अगर नेटवर्क आपका कम होगा स्लो होगा तो तब
भी आपकी जो क्वालिटी ऑफ वीडियो होती है
आपके अगर आप 360 पर देखोगे और 720 पर देखो
तो उसी हिसाब से आपकी डियो ऑडियो क्वालिटी
भी दी जाती है
तो मैं हमेशा अपनी वीडियो चेक करता हूं तो
मेरी तरफ से तो कभी लगा नहीं कि आफ्टर
रिकॉर्डिंग भी वॉल्यूम कम है
प्लीज आ जाइए जितना जल्दी हो सकते हैं
प्लीज कम
फास्ट जी नमस्ते नमस्ते कोई इशू नहीं
मेली क्लासेस नहीं ले सकते तो आई विल
ट्राई कि सेकंड नहीं तो थर्ड डे मैं आपकी
क्लासेस ले लूंगा सो दैट की जो प्रोफेशन
वर्किंग में है तो उनको भी टाइम मिल जाए
पढ़ने का जो स्टूडेंट्स होंगे उनको भी
टाइम मिल जाए बस मोस्टली आई विल ट्राई कि
थर्ड डे मैं आपकी क्लास ले
लूंगा सेकंड डे तो नहीं ले सकता तो एक दिन
छोड़ के तो एक क्लास लेनी पड़ेगी बट अभी
थोड़ा सा कुछ टाइम में अगर मैं बाहर
रहूंगा किसी भी कारण से तो मैं हो सकता है
कि कभी थ्री फोर डेज के बाद क्लास लू तो
ऐसा टाइम आएगा अभी बीच में तो शायद मे बी
आफ्टर सम क्लासेस या आफ्टर टू क्लासेस या
दिस क्लास तो थोड़ा सा डिले होगा मे बी
थ्री और फोर डेज के बाद क्लास लू देन उसके
बाद फिर कंटिन्यू मैं अपनी क्लासेस करूंगा
कि आफ्टर थ एवरी थर्ड डे तो मैं क्लासेस
100% लूंगा
सब लोग बताइए साउंड लो है
क्या ओनली टू स्टूडेंट्स जो बोल रहे हैं
कि साउंड लो है सर तो बाकी तो मुझे नहीं
किसी ने तो अभी तक बताया नहीं
मैं सेशन को स्टार्ट करता हूं
ओके जो सबसे पहला टॉपिक हम पढ़ेंगे ओ एसआई
मॉडल वर्सेस साइबर सिक्योरिटी हमने ओ एसआई
मॉडल पढ़ा था उसको हम साइबर अटैक्स जो जो
परफॉर्म होते हैं लेयर वाइज उनकी लिस्ट
आपको प्रोवाइड करूंगा तो थोड़ा सा
कंपैरिजन करेंगे हो सकता है कुछ चीजें
आपको नहीं पता हो तो आपको कुछ चीजें नई
सीखने को मिलेंगी और उसके बाद फिर हम
थोड़ा सा इन डेप्थ जाएंगे तो क्योंकि
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के लिए या कोई भी
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग आपका सर्टिफिकेट है
चाहे सीच है जीपीटी है ओ एससीपी है तो यह
पढ़ना ही पड़ेगा आपको मैं नहीं पढ़ाऊंगा
तो और कोई पढ़ाए जो अच्छे इंस्ट्रक्टर
होंगे ना वो आपको पढ़ाते ही हैं जरूरी
नहीं कि किसी ने नहीं पढ़ाया तो नहीं
पढ़ाता नहीं पढ़ाते हैं अगर आप डीसीएसपी
भी पढ़ोगे उसमें भी पढ़ाया जाता है यह चीज
कि हमारे कोर्स का पार्ट रहता ही रहता
नहीं जो अच्छे इंस्ट्रक्टर है जो वो
डेफिनेटली आपको ई मॉडल पढ़ाते हैं सबसे
पहले तो इसमें डाउट नहीं रखना चाहिए
ओके तो एक लास्ट क्लास में किसी ने एक
डाउट पूछा था कि सर डाउट बोर्ड पर मेंशन
कर दीजिए मेरा डाउट बोर्ड तो मैं आपको बता
देता हूं कि सर व पूछ रहे हैं मुझसे कि
जिनका नाम सचिन है विल यू कवर एंटायस इन
दिस कोर्स बाय स्टेप बाय स्टेप लाइक यू
कवर्ड ओ एसआई मॉडल टुडे और वी हैव टू
स्टडी दिस टॉपिक सेपरेटली देखिए इसका जवाब
मैं आपको सिंपली बता देता हूं कि मैं
कंप्लीट नेटवर्किंग कवर नहीं करूंगा
क्योंकि साइबर सिक्योरिटी में एज बिगनर टू
इंटरमीडिएट या आप पेन टेस्टिंग करनी है तो
कंप्लीट नेटवर्किंग आपको पढ़ने की जरूरत
नहीं है लेकिन इस कोर्स के लिए जो एथिकल
हैकिंग कोर्स है जो एक इसका एक लेवल है
बिगनर टू
इंटरमीडिएट उसके लिए जितने भी कांसेप्ट की
रिक्वायरमेंट है पढ़ने की चाहे वो ओ एसआई
मॉडल हो नेटवर्क के चाहे वो नेटवर्क
क्लियर हो या उसके जो भी प्रोटोकॉल्स की
रिक्वायरमेंट है जो हमें पता होना
चाहिए वह सारी चीजें मैं एक्सप्लेन खुद से
करूंगा उसकी चिंता करने की आपको जरूरत
नहीं है और जो मैं एक्सप्लेन नहीं करूंगा
और जो मुझे लगता है कि आपको यह पढ़ना
चाहिए तो मैं आपको बोल दूंगा कि प्लीज
इसको आप खुद से गो थ्रू कीजिए खुद से इस
पर रिसर्च कीजिए खुद से इसको पढ़ लीजिए यह
मैं बताऊंगा एनटायर
नेटवर्किंग आपका पार्ट नहीं है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में नेटवर्क इंजीनियर के लिए
एंटायस रिक्वायर्ड है बट बेसिक लेवल पर
जितना आपको पता होना चाहिए एज ए साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट बिगनर टू इंटरमीडिएट
उतना मैं आपको कवर करूंगा चाहे वो मैं अभी
कंटिन्यू कवर करूं या बीच-बीच में टॉपिक
के साथ कवर करूं जितना आपके लिए जरूरी है
एज ए पेन टेस्टर उतना मैं आपके लिए कवर
करूंगा ओके तो मे भी आपके जो डाउट था उसका
आंसर आपको मिल गया होगा और फिर भी अगर
फर्द आपको डाउट है तो फिर से मुझे कमेंट
सेक्शन में पूछ सकते हो अगर जो नए लोग हैं
उनको मैं तरीका बता देता हूं कि अगर आपको
डाउट पूछना है ड्यूरिंग क्लास जब मैं आपसे
पूछता हूं कि कि रिलेटेड टू टॉपिक की आपको
कोई भी डाउट है तो आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो
जब मैं आपसे पूछूंगा अदर वाइज लास्ट की जो
फ टू 10 मिनट होती है तब भी मैं आपसे
पूछता हूं कि कोई डाउट है क्या रिलेटेड टू
क्लास तब भी मुझसे पूछ सकते हो टॉपिक से
रिलेटेड पूछने के लिए बोलता हूं लेकिन आप
दूसरे डाउट पूछते हो फिर भी मैं उनको
बताता
हूं अगर इन दोनों चीजों के बीच में मैं
आपके कमेंट सेक्शन नहीं देख पाता स्किप हो
जाती है तो दूसरा तरीका यह है कि आपको
क्या करना जब यह वीडियो अपलोड हो जाती है
जैसे ही सेशन खत्म हो जाता है सेम टाइम
वीडियो
[संगीत]
youtube1 लाइ का है 15 लाइन का है या 20
लाइन का पूरा टाइप कर दीजिए सो दैट कि
मुझे भी समझ में आ जाए कि आपका क्या डाउट
आप क्या पूछना चाहते हो वो डाउट अगर सेम
टाइम क्लियर होने का होगा तो मैं आपको
रिप्लाई मैसेज में क्लियर कर दूंगा उसका
रिप्लाई कर दूंगा अदर वाइज उस डाउट को
डाउट बोर्ड पर लेकर आया जाएगा क्लास के
दौरान बताया जाएगा चाहे वह नेक्स्ट डे की
क्लास में बताया जाए या उसकी एक दो क्लास
में बताया जाए लेकिन उस डाउट को डिस्कस
डेफिनेटली किया जाएगा जब तक यह कोर्स चल
रहा है तो दिस इज द वे टू आस्क योर डाउट
यूटिलाइज द कमेंट सेक्शन एज ए मैसेज बॉक्स
दिस इज द बेस्ट वे टू यूटिलाइज द कमेंट
सेक्शन अब फालतू कमेंट करने की बजाय ऐसे
यूटिलाइज करो तो आपके लिए बेनिफिशियल होगा
और मेरे लिए भी बेनिफिशियल होगा कि मैं आप
लोगों का टाइम आप लोगों को टाइम दे पा रहा
हूं
ओके चलो अभी हम सेशन स्टार्ट करते हैं
ऑलरेडी 10 मिनट हो गई है और देर ओनली 61
स्टूडेंट्स मुझे लगता है यही एवरेज रहने
वाला है तो इट्स ओके तो जो मिस कर रहे हैं
मे बी जो रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे हैं अच्छी
बात है अदर वाइज जो मिस कर रहे हैं लाइव
सेशन को या सेशन देख ही नहीं रहे उनको
लगता कि बाद में कवर कर लेंगे तो शायद
अपनी जिंदगी में बहुत कुछ मिस कर रहे हैं
खासकर जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी में एंटर करना
चाहते हैं आपको पता चल जाएगा अपकमिंग टाइम
टाइम में और मैं भी बता दूंगा कि आप लोगों
ने क्या मिस किया है ओके
हां नोट्स से रिलेटेड हम आपको बता देता
हूं कि मैं ग्रुप में हम क्या है कि एक
लिमिटेशंस है ्र की खासकर चैनल वाले में
पीडीएफ लिंक में भेज नहीं पाते हम वहां पर
आप ड्राइव का
[संगीत]
लिखता हूं कि डे फाइव की क्लास में ये
पढ़ाया गया था ये उसका एक छोटी सी समरी है
या जो कुछ है उसमें ये वीडियो का लिंक
प्लस में नोट्स में फोटो के साथ उधर अपलोड
करता हूं तो आपको सिंपली क्या करना है डि
फोनिक्स अकेडमी के पेज प जाइए उधर जब उनके
फॉलोअर्स में देखोगे जो फॉलोइंग है जो
उनके साथ कनेक्शंस है जब कनेक्शंस में
जाओगे एस ए एम सेम नाम जैसे कि जैसे मैं
अभी मैसेज कर रहा हूं आपको हेलो करके तो
जो नाम इधर आएगा अभी जैसे कि आपके सामने
एक नाम आया तो उधर ही सेम ऐसे ही आएगा सेम
ठीक है जो सीओओ ऑफ द डे फोनिक्स अकेडमी तो
उस प्रोफाइल प जाइए तो वहां की सारी पोस्ट
आप क्या कर सकते हो देख सकते हो और अगर
आपको मेरे को फॉलो करना तो आप मेरे को
रिक्वेस्ट भे दीजिए मैं आपको एक्सेप्ट कर
लूंगा और दूसरा क्या है कि मैं सर से
रिक्वेस्ट कर दूंगा कि उस पोस्ट को
रीपोस्ट कर दे डेफरड में सो दैट कि वहां
पर भी अपडेट हो जाए तो मैं सर को बोल
दूंगा ये चीज ओके तो अगर वहां पर आपके डे
वन से लेकर डे फव तक सारे जितने भी पीडीएफ
थी सारी अवेलेबल है अब वहां पे आप देख
सकते हो ओके चलो
अगर आपको एन मैप से कोई वनटी मिलता है तो
रिपोर्ट कर
दीजिए चलो अभी बात करते हैं
देखो कि ओ एसआई मॉडल को हम कंपेयर करते
हैं साइबर सिक्योरिटी से देखिए सबको पता
है कि फिजिकल लेयर का सिग्निफिकेंट क्या
है फिजिकल लेयर का क्या काम है फिजिकल
लेयर पर क्या हो होता है क्योंकि ओ एसआई
मॉडल सबने पढ़ा होगा मेरी क्लास में ओके
तो नाउ वन क्वेश्चन फ्रॉम माय सेड एनी वन
इज अवेयर अबाउट एन अटैक दैट कुड हैपन एट
दिस लेयर किसी को कोई कुछ पता है कि जो
फिजिकल लेयर है उस पर कौन सा अटैक हो सकता
है साइबर अटैक किसी को पता है एनी वन एनी
वन नो कि कौन सा साइबर अटैक कर सकते हैं
हम सिल इस पे फिजिकल लेयर प देखिए आप का
गैस सही भी हो सकता है गलत भी हो सकता है
बट मुझे आंसर चाहिए कि इससे पता चल जाए
आपको पता है या नहीं
पता एनीथिंग एल्स
और कौन सा अटैक परफॉर्म कर सकते
हैं फिजिकल लेयर के ऊपर देखिए हमें पता
देखो फिजिकल लेयर पर जो पीडी होता है
प्रोटोकॉल डाटा यूनिट जो हैंडल की जाती है
वह बिट्स में की जाती है बिट्स का मतलब
क्या है कि वहां पर काम क्या है
इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल्स पास हो रहे हैं या
पल्सेस में आपका डाटा जा रहा है या लाइट
सिग्नल्स में डिजिटल सिग्नल्स में डाटा के
साथ डील किया जा रहा है लेकिन मैं जानना
चाहता हूं कि अगर यहां पर कोई साइबर अटैक
परफॉर्म करना है तो फिजिकल लेयर पर कौन सा
पॉसिबल है और होता भी है दे आर लॉट्स ऑफ
तो मे भी ठीक है आप ट्राई कर रहे हो बट नो
यहां अभी फिजिकल अटैक पर अभी कोई नहीं
पहुंच पाया
नहीं कुछ ट्राई कर रहे हैं तो उनका थोड़ा
सा रिलेशन कर रहा है बट एग्जैक्ट जो मुझे
आंसर चाहिए वो नहीं मिल रहा चलो मैं आपको
बताता हूं नेक्स्ट देखो एक सिनेरियो लेते
पहले देखो वो है
आपका साइड चैनल
अटैक कौन सा होता है आपका साइड चैनल अटैक
किसी को पता है साइड चैनल अटैक के बारे
में एनी वन नोज साइड चैनल
अटैक नाम सुना देखिए
चलो बताता हूं देखो क्या हो रहा है
आजकल मुझे एक चीज चेक करने दीजिए
ओके
अभ देखो आजकल अटैकर्स मतलब की अटैकर्स
क्या करते हैं किस टाइप की वह फोकस कर
देखो वन एवर डटा सेशन आर गोइंग
ऑन ट्राई टू अंडरस्टैंड द सेशन एल्गोरिदम
चलो इससे पहले मैं आपको समझाता हूं कि
मेनली अटैकर्स अभी साइड चैनल अटैक से पहले
मैं आपको सिनेरियो देता हूं अटैकर क्या
करते हैं अटैकर्स फोकस करते हैं ट्रेडिशनल
मोड ऑफ
सिक्योरिटी किस पर फोकस करते हैं
ट्रेडिशनल मोड ऑफ सिक्योरिटी बेसिकली
सॉफ्टवेयर बेस सिक्योरिटी क्या करते हैं
अटैकर्स कोई भी अटैकर है वह क्या करता है
कि पहले उसके कम्युनिकेशन चैनल को स्निप
करने की कोशिश करता है देन उसके बाद अगर
कम्युनिकेशन चैनल नहीं होता उसके बाद क्या
करता है दूसरा ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करता है
उस इंफॉर्मेशन के आधार पर जो इंफॉर्मेशन
उसके पास है दो यह चीजें और दूसरी चीज
ट्राई करता है लेकिन आजकल जो ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग है और स्निपिंग है इनके थ्रू
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करना बहुत
टिपिकल हो गया इसका कारण क्या है इसका
कारण है सिक्योरिटी सोलूशंस अब सिक्योरिटी
सोलूशंस क्या होते हैं आपके एंटीवायरस
आपके एंड पॉइंट डिटेक्शन जिसको आप ईडीआर
बोल सकते हो आईपीएस एंट्रोजन प्रिवेंशन
सिस्टम आईडीएस इंट्रूजन डिटेक्शन सिस्टम्स
या आपके जो एंड पॉइंट पर मॉनिटरिंग टूल्स
है आपके फ्लक कोन क्राउड साइड फ्लक कोन या
विंडोज डिफाइंड के जो अदर्स जो हाई लेवल
टूल्स है तो यह सारे क्या अपने आपको डे
बाय डे बाय क्या कर रहे हैं अपग्रेड कर
रहे हैं और जिससे क्या होगा कि सॉफ्टवेयर
के बेस पर स्निपिंग के थ्रू ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग के थ्रू क्या है कि इनफ इमेशन
गैदरिंग करना सेंसिटिव इफ गैदरिंग करना
क्या काफी डिफिकल्ट हो गया है अभी जब यह
सारी चीज डिफिकल्ट हो गई है तो अटैकर्स ने
क्या किया कि अब टेक्नोलॉजी पर फोकस कर
लिया टेक पर या दूसरे जो मोड्स थे उनके
थ्रू इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग स्टार्ट कर दिया
उनमें से एक मोड है साइड चैनल अटैक साइड
चैनल अटैक क्या होता है कैसे काम करता है
मैं बताता हूं देखिए व्हेन एवर डटा सेशन
आर गोइंग
ऑन दे ट्राई टू अंडरस्टैंड द सेशन
एल्गोरिथम अभी अटैकर्स क्या कर रहे हैं कि
जब भी कोई डाटा सेशन फॉर एग्जांपल ये एक
मेरा डिवाइस है मेरा यह पीसी है मेरा
लैपटॉप है अभी मैं एक सर्वर से
कम्युनिकेशन कर रहा हूं मेरा डाटा सेशंस
ऑन गोइंग है कि मेरे वेबसाइट एक्सेस कर
रहा हूं या कोर्स देख रहा हूं कुछ भी कर
रहा हूं मैं मैं पूरा डाटा क्या है
कम्युनिकेशन बना हुआ है अभी इस सेशन के
अंदर बहुत सारी एल्गोरिथम यूज होती है कोई
भी चाहे क्रिप्टोग्राफी एल्गोरिथम्स है या
कोई भी एल्गोरिथम्स है सिक्योरिटी
एल्गोरिथम्स है बहुत सारी एल्गोरिथम्स
यहां पर यूज हो र होती है तो अटैकर्स क्या
करते हैं अभी आज
इन सारी चीजों को क्या है एनालाइज करते
हैं समझने की कोशिश करते हैं एंड इन दज
एल्गोरिथम वन की इज वेरी वन थिंग इज वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट इन सारे एल्गोरिथम में एक चीज
क्या है बहुत कॉमन होगी खास कर के
क्रिप्टोग्राफी एल्गोरिथम क्योंकि
क्रिप्टोग्राफी क्या है कॉन्फिडेंशियल
मेंटेन करने का एक जरिया है उसमें सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट चीज क्या है की है एंड दिस इज
वेरी डिफिकल्ट टू अटैक एंड गेट इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट द कीज बाय अटैकिंग दीज एल्गोरिथम
अभी यह जो सारी फम जैसे की अगर की पर अटैक
करोगे आप की की जो एल्गोरिथम है
एसिमिट्रिक है सिमिट्रिक है आरएस है व्ट
एवर एल्गोरिथम है तोब उन पर अटैक करोगे तो
वहां से अगर की की इंफॉर्मेशन
गेटिंग करना गैदर करना बहुत टिपिकल है
मतलब आप व इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर ही नहीं
पाओगे कक इंफॉर्मेशन आप नहीं कर सकते सीधी
सी बात है तो अब यह सारी चीजें होने के
बावजूद क्या करते हैं अटैकर्स आर फोकसिंग
ऑन अदर डिटेल्स
दैट आर एसोसिएटेड विद दैट एल्गोरिथम फॉर
एग्जांपल इफ एल्गोरिथम इज रनिंग ऑन द
डिवाइस दे विल बी सम इलेक्ट्रोमैग्नेटिक
रेडिएशन वुड बी प्रोड्यूस्ड अभी जिस
डिवाइस में जो ये एल्गोरिथम्स रन कर रही
है वो कोई ना कोई तो इलेक्ट्रोमैग्नेटिक
रेडिएशन क्या कर रहा है प्रोड्यूस कर रहा
है कुछ हीट या लाइट वहां पर जनरेट हो रही
है या प्रोड्यूस हो रही है कुछ साउंड
साउंड क्रिएट हो रहा है उन सिस्टम्स की
वजह से अगर ये एल्गोरिथम्स अब लोड पड़ता
तो कोई भी पावर कंजप्शन हाई या लो रही है
यह सारी चीजें क्या है मॉनिटर की जा इन पे
फोकस करने लगे आजकल अटैकर्स तो ऑल दीज
पैरामीटर्स आर नोन एज साइड चैनल्स ये
जितने भी पैरामीटर्स हैं इनको हम बोलते
हैं साइड चैनल्स रदर देन फोकसिंग ऑन द
एक्चुअल इंफॉर्मेशन दैट आर पासिंग थ्रू द
डिवाइस दे आर फोकसिंग ऑन दीज एडिशनल
पैरामीटर्स सो दिस नोन एज साइड चैनल
अटैक्स अभी जो इनफॉर्मर एक्चुअल में फॉलो
फॉलो कर रही है किसके जो कम्युनिकेशन चैनल
के थ्रू उस परे फोकस ना करके जो एक्स्ट्रा
चीजें जैसे इलेक्ट्रोमैग्नेटिक रेडिएशन
होगी लाइट वेव्स होगी या जो भी उन परे
फोकस कर रहे हैं आजकल अटैकर्स तो यू आर इफ
यू आर नॉट इंटरेस्टेड इन सॉफ्टवेयर बेस
अटैक्स तो यू आर ट्राइट इंप्लीमेंट
हार्डवेयर बेस अटैक्स अगर आप सॉफ्टवेयर
बेस अटैक्स में इंटरेस्टेड नहीं हो या आप
नहीं कर पा रहे हो तो आप ट्राई क्या करते
हो फिर हार्डवेयर बेस अटैक परफॉर्म करने
की कोशिश करते हो एक्चुअली देयर आर लॉट ऑफ
साइड चैनल अटैक्स आर अवेलेबल जिनमें से एक
कोल्ड बूट अटैक किसी ने सुना है कोल्ड बूट
अटैक किसी ने भी एनी
वन एनी वन किसी ने कोल्ड बूट अटैक सुना है
नाम
नो
देखिए दिस अटैक इवॉल्व रम रैंडम एक्सेस
मेमोरी अ दिस इज द मेन मेमोरी इन आवर
डिवाइस एंड रम क्या है वोलेटाइल इन नेचर
एवरीवन एग्री सभी एग्री करते हो कि रम
क्या है वोलेटाइल इन नेचर मतलब यह सीपीयू
है सीपीयू के अंदर मदर मदर बोर्ड के अंदर
रम लगी हुई है और सबको पता है कि रम क्या
है वोलेटाइल है
मतलब हिंदी बोलो क्या है भाई हिंदी बात
हिंदी में तो बात कर रहा हूं
मैं इतना भी नहीं समझ में आता
क्या यू आर बिकमिंग साइबर सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल और आपको इतना भी समझ में नहीं
आता गुड क्या नाम है हर्ट वेरी
गुड चलो अभी क्या है कि जो कोल्ड बूट अटैक
है वो रम को इवोल्व करता है और रम क्या है
आपकी मेन मेमोरी है आपके डिवाइस के अंदर
और जो वोलेटाइल इन नेचर जो क्या आपका
वोलेटाइल इन
नेचर पबजी का सस्ता नशा भैया आपका मैं
जवाब दे चुका हूं एन मै से कौन स व मिला
तो क्या करूं क्या करूं मैं इसका जवाब दे
चुका हूं यार और अभी आप टॉपिक आउट ऑफ
टॉपिक बात ना कीजिए ओके तो देखि अप टिल
नाउ ऑल ऑफ वी अजूम दैट रम इज वोलेटाइल इन
नेचर बट बैक इन 2007
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर फाइंड आउट रम इज
वोलेटाइल ओनली टिल सर्टेन
टेंपरेचर 2017 में जो सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस
ने यह फाइंड आउट किया कि जो रैम है वह
वोलेटाइल है लेकिन एक सर्टेन टेंपरेचर तक
ही वोलेटाइल है वन यू कूल डाउन द रम टिल
माइनस 45 डिग्री सेल्सियस इट्स गोइंग टू
रिटेन इट स्टेट जिस स्टेट में वो
थी उसी स्टेट में रह जाएगी मतलब क्या कि
जिस कंडीशन में रम जो भी प्रोसेसेस होंगे
चाहे जो भी कुछ रम के अंदर चलर होगा लोड
होगा उस टाइम पर जब -45 डिग्री सेल्सियस
में अगर रम रम को लेकर आया जाए तो उसी
कंडीशन में रहेगी इट मींस एवरीथिंग वाज
देयर इन रम बिफोर यू टर्न ऑफ द कंप्यूटर
विल रिमन सेम अब दूसरा क्वेश्चन हो सर मैं
अपनी रम को कूल डाउन कैसे करूंगा थ्रो
कूलिंग स्प्रे थ्रो कूलिंग स्प्रे जो
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक एक्सपर्ट्स है वो य करते
हैं तो सिंपली क्या करोगे मेरा येय सीपीयू
सीपीयू मदरबोर्ड ओपन किया मैंने रम को
क्या किया अभी रनिंग रनिंग कंडीशन की बात
है पीसी में रनिंग में है फॉर एग्जांपल आप
एक क्या हो डिजिटल फॉरेस्टिंग टीप के एक
मेंबर है जहां पर आपको क्या करना है
सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन रिट्रीव करनी है अब
आपने एक पीसी पीसी मिला ठीक है क्राइम सीन
पे गया कहीं पर गया आपने क्या एक पीसी
मिला और पीसी के रनिंग कंडीशन में और एज
इट इज छोड़ के चला गया विक्टिम आपने क्या
किया कि उसके बॉक्स को ओपन किया और साइड
में मदर बोर्ड पर क्या किया आपने स्प्रे
यूज किया स्प्रे किया तो रैम को क्या कर
दिया -45 डिग्री तक क्या कर दिया कूल डाउन
कर दिया फ्रिज कर दिया और सिंपली आप क्या
करोगे उस टाइम पे कूल डाउन करके उसके बाद
उसका सीपीयू को ऑफ कर दिया उस रैम को
निकाल लिया निकाल के जो दूसरा सीपीयू था
उसकी उसके मदर बोर्ड में आपको क्या करना
है उस रैम को इंसर्ट करना है और सीपीयू को
ऑन करना है तो जिस कंडीशन में वो रैम थी
वहां पर दूसरे वाले सीपीयू में पहले वाले
सीपीयू में उसी कंडीशन में वो रैम क्या
उसकी जो सी सारी प्रोसेसस है उसके अंदर जो
भी पासवर्ड्स होंगे जो भी इंफॉर्मेशन होगी
जब यह रम स्विच ऑफ होने से पहले कूल डाउन
होने से पहले वो सारी की सारी सेम
इंफॉर्मेशन एज इट इज आपको उस रम में देखने
को मिलेगी उसकी मेमोरी में दिस इज द कोल्ड
बोट अटैक्स इजी अटैक नहीं है बट हार्ड है
लेकिन पॉसिबल है मतलब यह एक ऐसा अटैक है
तो मैं भी शायद इससे कोई अवेयर नहीं था य
बहुत सारे लोग इससे अवेयर नहीं होंगे कि
सर की कोल्ड वट अटैक तो कोल्ड बुक अटैक
करना पॉसिबल है आप कर सकते हो एज ए डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक एक्सपर्ट्स जब आप उस टीम में काम
कर रहे हो तो आपके को पता होना चाहिए कि
ओके मैं कोल्ड बूट अटैक परफॉर्म करके इस
पीसी से सेंसिटिव इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग कर
सकता हूं खासकर जब आप डिजिटली डील कर रहे
उससे मतलब एक ऐसी टीम का हिस्सा होगा जहां
पर आपके पास ये सारी चीजें करने का एक्सेस
हो ओके
एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि ट व्ट इज द साइड
व्हाट इज द कल्ड कोल्ड बूट
अटैक सबको पता चल गया
चलो
अभी देखो साइड चैनल अटैक में तो एक पार्ट
था देर अदर लॉट ऑफ अटैक्स ट यू कैन
परफॉर्म इन साइड चैनल अटैक्स चलो मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं कि वो कौन-कौन से अटैक्स और
अवेलेबल है लिस्ट अवेलेबल है चलो मैं आपको
एक वेबसाइट के थ्रू दिखा देता हूं नाउ गो
बैक एंड दे लिस्ट है आपको आप क्या करोगे
एचटीटीपीएस उसका नाम है
य यहां पर देखिए जितने भी जो साइड चैनल
अटैक्स है लिस्ट ऑफ साइड चैनल अटैक्स आपको
मिल जाएगी मतलब जो हार्डवेयर बेस अटैक जो
परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं उनके ऊपर आर्टिकल्स
अवेलेबल है उनके ऊपर आर्टिकल्स अवेलेबल
है ओके चलो मैं आपको इसकी लिस्ट भेज देता
हूं ग्रुप में इसका लिंक भेज देता हूं यह
रहा कंट्रोल व
जो ग्रुप में जो फालतू की जो बकवास कर रहे
हैं
ना चलो
देखिए रेस्प पाई डाटा एक्सट्रैक्शन कोल्ड
बूट अटैक्स आप इन पर क्लिक करके पढ़ सकते
हो इनमें से मैं आपको और चीज बताता हूं
जैसे कि एक अटैक है आपको वैसे आप खुद से
पढ़ लीजिए इस लिस्ट को कभी भी आपको अगर मन
करे तो पार्ट ऑफ सिलेबस नहीं है बट मैं
आपको एक एक्स्ट्रा इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड कर
रहा हूं यहां पर जैसे कि ये रहा एच वकर
यूज एवक सिस्टम टू कंट्रोल मालवेयर ऑन एयर
गैप सिस्टम मतलब ये रहा देख 22 पे अगर मैं
इसको ओपन करूंगा न्यू पेज पे तो अगर ये एक
अटैक था हैकर्स में यहां पर क्या किया जो
आपका जो एसी होते है ना जो एयर कंडीशंस
होते हैं जो सर्वर्स रूम में यूज किए जाते
हैं या जो आपकी सर्वर यूनिट है उसके अंदर
क्या है कि कूलिंग मैकेनिज्म होता है
जिसमें क्या एसीज का यूज किया जाता है एयर
कंडीशनर का सर्वर के इनबिल्ट पार्ट होते
हैं अगर कभी देखोगे तो ठीक है तो उस एसी
का यूज करके एयर कंडीशनर का यूज करके
अटैकर्स मालवेयर रन कर रहे थे दिस टाइप ऑफ
अटैक ये इस टाइप का अटैक है देखिए यहां पर
कि उस एयर कंडीशन सिस्टम का यूज करके
मालवेयर रन किया जा रहा था ओके देखिए ये
रहा एक य अटैक्स है जैसे कि यूज एविक
सिस्टम टू कंट्रोल मालवेयर ऑन एयर ग्रैबड
सिस्टम ओके मालवेयर को कंट्रोल किया जा था
एयर कंडीशनर का यूज करके शायद आपको पता भी
नहीं होगा इन सारे अटैक्स का आप देख लीजिए
नाउ एक और अटैक आपको दिखाऊंगा अगर मैं
इसमें यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा एयर वाइबर
स्टल डाटा यूजिंग अ कंप्यूटर फैन
वाइब्रेशन जो आपका पीसी है उसके अंदर फैंस
होता है कूलिंग डाउन करने के लिए उसकी जो
वाइब्रेशन है उस वाइब्रेशन का यूज करके
अटैकर्स ने इंफॉर्मेशन स्टील की है इसको
भी आप पढ़ सकते हो इस आर्टिकल के बारे में
पढ़ सकते हो मतलब दे लॉट ऑफ आर्टिकल्स आर
अवेलेबल जो एक्चुअल में हुए हैं यह
आर्टिकल सारे हुए हैं चैनल अटैक्स के
एग्जांपल है दे टोटल 30 30 अटैक्स देर
लिस्ट ऑफ अटैक्स हु विल बी
परफॉर्म बेस्ड ऑफ फिजिकल लेयर तो यह आपके
सारे साइड चैनल अटैक
है चलो तो यह थी लिस्ट आपके साइड चैनल
अटैक्स की और यह था आपका फिजिकल लेयर
अटैक्स तो एवरीवन गट क्लियर मे बी सबके
डाउट क्लियर होंगे कि साइड चन अटैक क्या
होता है उनमें से एक अटैक मैंने एक्सप्लेन
कर दिया और आपके सामने लिस्ट बता दी की व
कि फिजिकल लेयर पर कौन-कौन से अटैक
परफॉर्म किए जा सकते हैं तो अग मुझे लगता
कि बहुत लोगों के लिए नहीं कि बहुत सारे
स्टूडेंट्स के लिए यह एक न्यू इंफॉर्मेशन
थी शायद बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट को पता भी
नहीं था
नेक्स्ट करते हैं अभी नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर
चलते हैं
हम कि नाउ डेटा लिंक लेयर तो डेटा लिंक
लेयर क्या क्या सिग्निफिकेंट है क्या काम
है डेटा लिंक लेयर पर क्या काम होता है यह
सब मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन कर चुका हूं तो
डेटा लिंक प्लेयर पर जो अटैक्स परफॉर्म
किए जाते हैं उनकी लिस्ट मैं आपके सामने
शो कर देता हूं जैसे मैक्स पुपिंग आपके
डटा लिंक लेयर पे आर् स् पुपिंग पॉइजनिंग
फ्रेम स् पुपिंग मैक फलंग वलन हपिंग
एमआईटीएम डोस डीस सिग्नल जैमिंग स्विच
स्पिंग इथरनेट फ्रेम मैनिपुलेशन या डब्लू
लन अटैक्स ये सारे अटैक्स किसके ऊपर
परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं आपके डटा लिंक लेयर
के ऊपर परम किए जाते हैं दि आर द लिस्ट ऑफ
अटैक्स ट आर परफॉर्म न डेटा लिंक लेयर ओके
तो ये डेटा लिंक लेयर के ऊपर परफॉर्म किए
जाते हैं नाउ नेक्स्ट चलते हैं नेटवर्क
लेयर तो नेटवर्क लेयर क्या काम करती है और
इसके ऊपर क्या काम होता है मैं बता चुका
हूं कि यहां पर डाटा की डेटा को पैकेज की
फॉर्म में डील किया जाता है तो इसके पर जो
अटैक्स पॉसिबल है उनमें है आईपी स्पूफिंग
बीजीपी हाईजैकिंग एमआईटीएम याद परफॉर्म
किया जाता है पिन ऑफ डेथ
अटैक यर ड्रॉप अटैक आईपी फ्लड अटैक डीएनएस
स्पिंग आईपी फ्रेगमेंटेशन अटैक राउटिंग
प्रोटो एक्सप्लोइट यह सारे अटैक्स नेटवर्क
लेयर के ऊपर परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं और हम
अभी नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पर चलते हैं तो यहां
तक मुझे देखो यहां पर मुझे अगर आपको जानना
है कि यह अटैक क्या होता है तो इनमें से
बहुत सारे तो हम क्या कि ड्यूरिंग अपने
क्लासेस में ऑटोमेटिक कांसेप्ट के थ्रू
सीख लेंगे अभी बहुत सारे नए अटैक्स होंगे
जो आपने सुने भी नहीं होंगे तो अगर आपको
इन परे फर्द रिसर्च करनी है तो टैक्स के
नाम आपके सामने हैं आप ग करके अटैक्स के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन गैदर कर सकते हो पता
कर सकते हो कि ओके ये किस टाइप का अटैक है
कैसे परफॉर्म किया जाता है हर एक अटैक को
अभी मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा तो पूरा
थोरेट्स बन जाएगा जो मैं नहीं चाहता मैं
सिर्फ आपके सामने लिस्ट प्रोवाइड कर रहा
हूं ओके अभी दिखाते हैं हम ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेयर के अब ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर का काम क्या
है और ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर प किस टाइप का
अटैक होते हैं मैं आपको बताते देखो टीसीपी
सीन फ्लड फ्लड टीसीपी सेशन हाईजैकिंग
टीसीपी सीक्वेंस नंबर प्रेडिक्शन टीसीपी
रिसेट अटैक टीसीपी यूडीपी पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
यूडीपी फ्लड अटैक डीएनएस एमप्लीफिकेशन
अटैक एक्नॉलेजमेंट फ्लड अटैक टीसीपी
विंडोज साइज अटैक और फायर वल इवेज
टेक्निक्स ये सारी सारी किस लेयर पर काम
करती हैं ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पर अभी हमारे
कोर्स के लिए या कोई भी पेनिट्रेशन
टेस्टिंग कोर्स है तो सारे के सारे किस पर
फोकस करते हैं ज्यादातर ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
पर सो सारे के सारे जितने भी पेनिट्रेशन
सर्टिफिकेशन है दे आर टोटली फोकस्ड ऑन
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर व्हाई इसका कारण है देखो
देर टू बिग प्रोटोकॉल्स वर्किंग हियर दो
प्रोटोकॉल्स है एक तो टीसीपी और यूडीपी
ओके अभी जो नीचे की जो तीन लेयर हैं
नेटवर्क डेटा लिंक फिजिकल लेयर वो क्या
काम आती है नॉर्मली आपका हार्डवेयर लेयर
की तरफ ही काम करती है हार्डवेयर लेयर ही
हम उसको काउंट करते हैं एक प्रकार से अब
उसके बाद देखो ये जो मेन परपज है व कहां
से स्टार्ट होता है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर से
कम्युनिकेशन परपस एंड टू एंड कनेक्शन कहां
पर स्टार्ट होता है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर पर
तो अभी फॉर एग्जांपल हम क्लासेस अटेंड
करते हैं
[संगीत]
आर आईपी तो यह दो प्रोटोकॉल साथ में काम
कर रहे होंगे कैसे यहां पर क्या है बीच
में कैसे काम कर रहा हो देख फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने बात की आपके आपसे और वीडियो दोनों
एक साथ काम परफॉर्म कर रहे हैं य दोनों
दोनों सबसे पहले जैसे ही मैं अपनी तरफ से
बोल रहा हूं तो ये सबसे पहले सेंट्रलाइज
एक सर्वर होगा किसका य का सर्वर होगा उस
परे अपलोड हो रही है और सेम टाइम वहां से
आपकी स्क्रीन पर अपलोड हो रही है तो इस
तरीके से यहां पर कम्युनिकेशन चल रहा है
इस तरीके से सेशन एस्टेब्लिश मेंट हो रखा
है तो सारा खेल क्या है सबसे पहले यहां पर
ये जो सेटअप हुआ जो हमसे बात करने के लिए
जो सेशन सेटअप हुआ वो किसके थ्रू हुआ
टीसीपी लेयर के थ्रू एक कारण तो ये
इंपोर्टेंट दूसरा क्या है कि इट इज द हर्ट
ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल ये हर्ट आपका ओआई मॉडल
स्पेसिफिक रीजंस बहुत सारे स्पेसिफिक रीजन
है जैसे कि अगर मुझे किसी भी आईपी एड्रेस
से रिलेटेड यह पता करना हो कि उसके ऊपर
कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस एक्टिव है तो वो मैं
किसके थ्रू पता कर सकता हूं ट्रांसपोर्ट
लेर के थ्रू ओके अब सर्विसेस चाहे यूडीपी
बेस्ड हो चाहे सर्विस आपकी टीसीपी बेस्ड
हो देखो एक चीज है सर्टिफिकेट चाहे आपका
ईजी पीएटी हो चाहे आपका सीच प्रैक्टिकल हो
या सीच हो थ थोट कल की बात नहीं कर रहा
मैं प्रैक्टिकल की बात कर रहा हूं चाहे
ओससीपी हो सारे के सारे क्या है ब्लैक
बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग करवाते हैं सभी के सभी
क्या करवाते हैं आपको ब्लैक बॉक्स पन
टेस्टिंग मतलब क्या है आपको एक आईपी दे
दिया उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है ब्लाइंड
आप उस परे हंट करना है उसपे इंफॉर्मेशन
गैदरिंग करनी है उसपे अटैक करना है वनटी
फाइंड आउट करनी है और आप आपको फ्लैग
ढूंढना है तो ये टोटली क्या है ब्लैक
बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग सारे के सारे क्या है
ब्लैक बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग सर्टिफिकेशन है
वाइट बॉक्स पन टेस्टिंग सर्टिफिकेशन भी
अवेलेबल है मार्केट में लेकिन वाइट बॉक्स
जो पन टेस्टिंग है वह बहुत हार्ड होती है
क्योंकि वहां पर आपको इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
की जाती है तो एक बात समझिए जहां पर आपको
आपको पहले से इंफॉर्मेशन दी गई है किसी
टारगेट के बारे में तो सोच ले वहां पर और
भी ज्यादा हमें डीप जाकर इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड
आउट करने की जो जरूरत मतलब कि जो चीजें
शायद बहुत हार्ड है क्योंकि ब्लैक बॉक्स
में हम ब्लाइंड ली करते हैं लेकिन वाइट
बॉक्स में एक अप्रोच में काम करना तो
हमारे पास बहुत सारी नॉलेज होनी चाहिए तो
यह सारे सर्टिफिकेशन जो भी अभी हम पढ़ रहे
हैं या जो भी आप सर्टिफिकेशन सबसे पहले
देते हो वह सारे सर आप ब्लैक बॉक्स पन
टेस्टिंग ही देते हो चाहे बग बाउंट भी
करते हो तो वो भी आप क्या करते हो ब्लैक
बॉक्स ही प अटैक करते हो बाउंट परफॉर्म
करते हो तो यह थी कहानी ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर
की क्योंकि देखो डाटा लेयर हमें मैक
एड्रेस प्रोवाइड करता है नेटवर्क लेयर
हमें प्रोवाइड करता है आईपी एड्रेस और
ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर हमें क्या करता है
प्रोवाइड करता है पोर्ट नंबर तो दिस इज द
रोल ऑफ ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर इन ओआई मॉडल और
इन आवर साइबर सिक्योरिटी जननी तो अभी मैं
आपको बता देता हूं सेशन लेयर सेशन लेयर का
काम आप लोगों को पता है तो सेशन लेयर पर
जो अटैक परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं सेशन
हाईजैकिंग सेशन फिक्सेशन अटैक सेशन रिप्ले
अटैक डोस अटैक इस पर भी परफॉर्म किया जाता
है सेशन टाइम आउट न और फलंग अटैक या एक्स
एक्टेशन ऑफ सेशन कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल सीएसआरएफ सबको पता है
क्रेडेंशियल स्निफिंग अटैक सेशन टोकन
स्निफिंग बफर ओवरफ्लो अटैक सेशन स्टेट
मैनिपुलेशन या ऑथेंटिकेशन
बायपास यह मैंने थोड़े से जो पॉपुलर
अटैक्स है उनकी लिस्ट आपके सामने परफॉर्म
की है वैसे इनसे भी ज्यादा लिस्ट आपको मिल
जाएगी डीप
में उसके बाद आपके पास प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर
है कि प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर का क्या काम है वो
आपको पता है तो प्रेजेंटेशन लेवल पर जो
अटैक परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं आपके डाटा
इंटरसेप्शन या एवेज ड्रॉपिंग एसएसएल टी
एलएस ट्रिपिंग एसएसएल टी एलएस सर्टिफ
स्पूफिंग डाटा इंजेक्शन अटैक्स इंक्रिप्शन
वीकनेस और फ्लो एक्सप्लोइटेशन डाटा करप्शन
और मॉडिफिकेशन एक्सेसेस इनकोडिंग डिकोडिंग
वलने बिटीज फजिंग अटैक्स या की मैनेजमेंट
या वीक की जनरेशन यह सारे क्या है आपके
प्रेजेंटेशन लेयर अटैक्स हैं और भी अटैक्स
हो सकते हैं बट मैं आपको क्या कि थोड़े
फिल्टर आउट करके लिस्ट दे रहा हूं नेक्स्ट
जो एप्लीकेशन लेयर है एप्लीकेशन लेयर पर
जो अटैक परफॉर्म किए जाते हैं एसक्यूएल आई
आरसी कमांड इंजेक्शन फाइल इंक्लूजन वलने
बिटीज सेशन हाईजैकिंग सेशन फिक्सेशन ब्रूट
फोर्स अटैक फिशिंग या स्पीयर फिश अटैक
डायरेक्टरी ट्रैवर्सल जीरो डे
एक्सप्लोइट्स मालवेयर रसम वेयर अटैक्स
एपीआई सिक्योरिटी वलन बिटीज प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन या सोशल इंजीनियर अटैक्स ये
सारे सारे आपके एप्लीकेशन लेयर अटैक्स हैं
तो दिस वा द फेमिनाइजेशन विद साइबर
सिक्योरिटी वर्सेस ओएआई मतलब ओएआई लेयर और
जो साइबर सिक्योरिटी के
का जो एक फैमिल इजेशन था मैंने आपको बता
दिया कि किस टाइप के अटैक परफॉर्म किए
जाते हैं इन अपने फर्द कोर्स में हम क्या
करने वाले हैं बहुत सारे अटैक्स होंगे
देखो जो वेब पन टेस्टिंग है जो बग बाउटी
में आप बहुत सारे अटैक परफॉर्म कर भी चुके
हो आपको पता है कैसे अटैक परफॉर्म करना है
कुछ जो अटैक्स है बहुत सारे अटैक्स हम
अपने अपकमिंग क्लासेस में हम सीखने वाले
हैं कि य अटैक कैसे काम करता है कौन सा
टूल यूज किया जाता है और हम लैब के थ्रू
उनको सीखेंगे तो डोंट वरी सारे अटैक्स तो
नहीं होंगे क्योंकि बहुत सार अटैक्स है जो
अलग लेवल पर किए जाते हैं और एडवांस लेवल
के हैं तो एडवांस लेवल का कोर्स नहीं है
ये बिगनर टू इंटरमीडिएट है तो जितना आपके
कोर्स की रिक्वायरमेंट उतनी यहां पर
फुलफिल की जाएगी आपकी ओके तो बहुत सारे
टैक्स हम सीखने भी वाले हैं तो ट वाज द
कंपैरिजन ऑफ ओ एसआई वर्सेस साइबर
सिक्योरिटी तो मे बी स्टिल नो डाउट्स आपके
इसमें तो अगर आपका कोई डाउट है तो प्लीज
अभी बता दीजिए मुझे चैट सेक्शन में तो हम
नेक्स्ट कंटिन्यू करते हैं अपने सेशन को
अभी फर्द
य दीपांशु प्रैक्टिकल्स जिनके बहुत सारे
के पॉसिबल है व हम परफॉर्म करेंगे अपकमिंग
क्लासेस में
जो अटैक्स आरसी है एसकल आई है तो अब कमिंग
क्लासेस में परफॉर्म हो जाएंगे डोंट
वरी परफॉर्म करेंगे
हम तो अटैक का नाम और चट जीपीटी कर लिए चट
जीपीटी आपका अटैक के बारे में ब्रीफ
डिस्क्रिप्शन देगी आप वोह किसी को समझा भी
सकते हो और आपको बहुत ही इजी लैंग्वेज में
समझ में आ
जाएगा ओके यारा शुभम अगर आप चैट जीपीटी पर
करोगे अटैक का नाम सर्च करके तो आपको काफी
डिटेल्स में आपको बता देगा कि अटैक कैसे
परफॉर्म होता है हर एक अटैक को बता देगा
चैट जीपीटी
ग की तरह उसको भी यूज करके देखो एक
बार इट्स वेरी
गुड अटैक नहीं दिखाएगा आपको क्योंकि व
उनकी प्राइवेसी पॉलिसी के खिलाफ है बट
आपको समझा देगा कि अटैक क्या
है चैट जीपीटी आपको एक्सप्लेन कर देगा अदर
वाइज आप ग भी करोगे तब भी आर्टिकल्स आपको
मिल
जाएंगे एन मैप की क्लास में भी अभी
स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी आज और एक सेशन और छोड़
के मे भी थर्ड सेशन एन मैप से स्टार्ट है
वो भी शुभम अगर आपको ओ एसआई मतलब क्या
बोला गया एक दो लाइन में किसी को बताना है
कि सारी लेयर के बारे में तो मैंने हां
सुबह मैंने एक स्लाइड आपको शायद अगर नहीं
याद हो तो चलो मैं आपको बता देता हूं कि
यह रहा आपको सारी लेयर के बारे में
एक्सप्लेन करना तो मैंने बताया था अगर
आपको कोई पूछ भी लेता ये रहा दिस वन दिस द
परफेक्ट टेक द स्क्रीनशॉट मैंने आपको
बताया था कि सारी सेवन लेयर के बारे में
कि कैसे कम्युनिकेशन प्रोसेस किया जाता है
फ्रॉम वन कंप्यूटर टू ईच कंप्यूटर दिस इ द
परफेक्ट एग्जांपल आप बाय लाइन ऐसे बताओगे
एक तो टेक्निकल वे है दूसरा क्या है कि व
समझ जाएगा जिसको टेक्निकल नॉलेज है व समझ
जाएगा अदर वाइज क्या कि इन लेयर के साथ
एग्जांपल जोड़ लो तो इट्स वेरी वेल
एक्सप्लेन एक य है साथ में क्याय य दोनों
कॉमिनेशन आप बताओगे तो किसी को भी समझ में
आ जाएगा व एसई
लेर चलो तो हम अभी चलते हैं अपने कंटिन्यू
ना एप्लीकेशन लेयर हो गई हो गई हो गया
चलो अभी हमारे लिए सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
लेयर्स है ट्रांसपोर्ट लेयर और नेटवर्क
लेयर थोड़ा सा फर्द इनके बारे में जो कुछ
इंटरनल इंफॉर्मेशन है जो प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं
जो हमारे लिए इंपोर्टेंट है जानना उनके
बारे में हम पढ़ेंगे उसके बाद हम
प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म करेंगे दीज टू लेयर्स
आर मोर फोकस लेयर ड्यूरिंग एक्टिव
इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग चलो इनको एक्सप्लोर
करते हैं और सबसे पहले जो एक्सप्लोर
करेंगे हम नेटवर्क लेयर के बारे में बात
करेंगे अभी देखो अभी सभी को पता है कि
नेटवर्क लेयर का सिग्निफिकेंट क्या है अगर
नहीं पता फिर भी मैं आपको बता देता हूं
आपके सामने फिर से मैं मेंशन कर रहा हूं
कि एक मतलब कि एक ब्रीफ वे में कि दिस इज
द मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट लेयर ऑफ द ओ एसआई मॉडल
दैट यू नीड टू अंडरस्टैंड एज ए
पेंटेस्टर इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर लॉजिकल
एड्रेस राउटिंग फॉरवर्डिंग डेटा पैकेट
बिटवीन डिवाइज अक्रॉस डिफरेंट नेटवर्क्स
ओके थर्ड इट्स प्राइमरी गोल टू डिटरमाइंड
द
ऑप्टिमल पाथ फॉर डाटा टू ट्रेवल फ्रॉम
सोर्स टू
डेस्टिनेशन फोर्थ अभी तीन पॉइंट्स आपको
समझ में आ गया अभी जब भी हम बात करते हैं
व्हेन वी आर टॉकिंग अबाउट
इंटरनेट व्ट द नेटवर्क लेयर इज
फैसिलिटेटिंग इज अलांग यू टू विद इन योर
होम नेटवर्क टू कम्युनिकेट विद अदर
नेटवर्क अक्रॉस द वर्ल्ड अभी यह जो फोर्थ
लाइन आपको नहीं समझ में आई होगी मैं आपको
समझाता हूं जब भी मैं इंटरनेट यूज करता
हूं तो नेटवर्क लेयर ऐसा क्या करती है कि
जो मेरा होम नेटवर्क से नेटवर्क से हम
अक्रॉस द वर्ल्ड जो नेटवर्क है उसके साथ
कम्युनिकेशन कर पाते हैं तो नेटवर्क लेयर
क्या करते है यहां पर इंश्योर करती है कि
आपका जो पैकेट है करेक्ट डेस्टिनेशन पर
डिलीवर हो जाए क्योंकि यह सोर्स एड्रेस और
डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस अपने पैकेट के अंदर
मेंशन करती है अब जब बात पैकेट की आई गई
है तो पैकेट क्या होता है मैं आपको बता
देता हूं देखो व्हाट इज पैकेट पैकेट आर
नथिंग बट टिम्स ऑफ बिट्स दैट आर रनिंग एज
इलेक्ट्रिक सिग्नल ऑन द फिजिकल मीडिया दैट
आर यूज्ड फॉर ट्रांसमिशन फॉर एग्जांपल
इथरनेट या वाईफाई ये आपका पैकेट के बारे
में थोड़ी सी इंफॉर्मेशन थी दीज
इलेक्ट्रिक सिग्नल्स आर देन इंटरप्रिटेड
एज बिट्स जीरो और वन दैट मेक अप द
इंफॉर्मेशन
देखिए पैकेट में क्या है स्ट्रीम्स ऑफ बिट
है कहने का मतलब क्या है कि जब इथरनेट या
वाईफाई राउटर के थ्रू जो डटा है आपका
सिग्नल्स की फॉर्म में ट्रेवल करता है
चाहे वो इलेक्ट्रिकल सिग्नल हो चाहे वो
लाइट सिग्नल हो लाइट सिग्नल की बात कर रहा
हूं तो आपके ऑप्टिकल केबल के थ्रू चाहे वह
आपके रेडियो मैग्नेटिक वेव्स हो आपकी
इलेक्ट्रो वाईफाई के थ्रू आपका जो डेटा है
वो ट्रेवल करता है इलेक्ट्रिक सिग्नल्स के
फॉर्म में जीरो और वन देन उसके बाद फिर से
दूसरे एंड प उनको कन्वर्ट किया जाता है जो
रिक्वायरमेंट है एज पर ओआई मॉडल ओके और
ऊपर से क्या है कि सारा डाटा आपका प की
फॉर्म में ट्रांसफर किया जाता है एवरी
पैकेट इन एवरी प्रोटोकॉल है द फॉलोइंग
स्ट्रक्चर हर एक प्रोटोकॉल में चाहे पैकेट
कोई भी उसका एक स्ट्रक्चर्स होता है जिसके
अंदर दो चीजें होती हैं एक तो हेडर होता
है दूसरा पेलोड होता है अब यह हेडर क्या
होता है इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन अबाउट द
पैकेट वयर इट कम्स फ्रॉम एंड वेयर इट इज
इंटेंड टू अराउ मतलब पैकेट कहां से आया है
डेस्टिनेशन इंफॉर्मेशन एज वेल एज सम मेटा
डेटा इंफॉर्मेशन दैट आर इंपोर्टेंट फॉर
फॉर एफिशिएंट डिलीवरी ऑफ पैकेट्स बेसिकली
क्या है हेडर के अंदर वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है जैसे सोर्स एड्रेस आपका
डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस या वह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
कि पैकेट को डिलीवर होने के लिए चाहिए वन
स्टे
वन पॉइंट टू अनदर पॉइंट जो पेलोड होता है
पेलोड के अंदर एक्चुअल डाटा होता है जो
पेलोड आपका उसके अंदर क्या होता है आपका
एक्चुअल डाटा होता है अभी हम फर्द चलते
हैं नाउ देयर आर सेवरल की प्रोटो कॉल्स
ऑपरेट्स ऑन द नेटवर्क लेयर ऑफ द एसआई मॉडल
एंड वन ऑफ देम व्हिच इज मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
एज ए पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर आर देखिए वैसे तो
बहुत सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स हैं जो मैंने आपको
लिस्ट आउट करके दिखाया था ड्यूरिंग द
स्लाइड कि ओआई मॉडल में नेटवर्क ले के ऊपर
इतने सारे प्रोटोकॉल्स ऑपरेट किए जाते हैं
उनमें से सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट
प्रोटोकॉल्स है वो है आपका इंटरनेट
प्रोटोकॉल आईपी जो एज ए पेंटेस्टर हमारे
लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है देखो यह
क्या करता है इसकी फंक्शन के बारे में
जानते
इट इज रिस्पांसिबल फॉर लॉजिकल एड्रेस
राउटिंग फ्रेगमेंटेशन एंड रिअसेंबलिंग ऑफ
डाटा पैकेट य जो जो जिस जिस फंक्शन की बात
मैंने की थी नेटवर्क लेयर पर वह किसके
थ्रू होती है आपके आईपी प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू
आईपी लेयर सर्व एज ए लॉजिकल एड्रेस दैट इज
असाइन टू नेटवर्क इंटरफेस अभी क्या जो
आईपी प्रोटोकॉल में आईपी एड्रेस होता है
जो क्या करता है एक लॉजिकल एड्रेस की तरह
काम करता है जो नेटवर्क इंटरफेस होते हैं
उनको प्रोवाइड किया जाता है दज एड्रेस
हेल्प्स टू यूनिकल
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
का इट इनेबल्स कम्युनिकेशन बिटवीन डिवाइस
ऑन ए डिफरेंट नेटवर्क्स बाय प्रोवाइड ए
स्टैंडर्डाइज वे टू आइडेंटिफिकेशन
होस्ट को लोकेट और
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
है आईपी प्रोटोकॉल के अंदर वो है आईपीवी फ
जो एक 32 बिट का एड्रेस है जो आपको देखने
को इस तरीके से मिला जैसे
192.168 या 10
10.4.2 या
17688 समथिंग लाइक दैट इस तरीके से जो
आपको आईपी एड्रेस देखने को मिलता है यह
आपका आईपीवी फ है ओके ईच आईपीवी फ एड्रेस
इज रिप्रेजेंटेड एज फोर सेट्स ऑफ
ऑक्टेट्स ओके नाउ आईपीवी 4 प्रोवाइड्स ए
फाइना इट एड्रेस स्पेस व्हिच जज लीड टू द
एडॉप्शन ऑफ आईपीवी स अभी जो आईपीवी 4 है
एक फाइना इट एड्रेस स्पेस आपको प्रोवाइड
करता है मतलब अभी वैसे तो बहुत ज्यादा
अमाउंट में जैसे-जैसे अब नेटवर्क्स बढ़
रहे हैं जैसे-जैसे इनकी रिक्वायरमेंट बढ़
रही है वैसे-वैसे अब आईपी एड्रेस भी
फुलफिल हो रहे हैं तो इसी वजह से अभी
आईपीवी सि भी धीरे-धीरे एडॉप्शन हो रहा है
तो जो आईपीवी सि है इट वाज डेवलप टू ओवरकम
द लिमिटेशंस ऑफ आईपीवी फो एंड प्रोवाइड ए
सिग्निफिकेंट लार्ज एडस स्पेस यूजिंग 128
बिट्स एड्रेस जो आईपीवी आईवी जो सि है
आपका वह क्या है आपका 128 बिट का एड्रेस
होता है जो हेक्साडेसिमल में आपको देखने
को मिलेगा इस तरीके
से समथिंग यह एक एग्जांपल है तो आप इस
तरीके से देख सकते हो कि आईपीवी सि एड्रेस
इस तरीके से आपको देखने को
मिलेगा ट
फोर सेट्स ऑफ ऑक्ट फोर
ऑक्टेट्स
न ऑक्ट इक्वल टू 8 बिट इसलिए क्या 32 बिट
एड्रेस
हैय सबको समझ में
आया यहां
तक एवरीवन गट
क्लियर यस आईपीवी सि भी यूज होता है
बड़ी-बड़ी कंपनिया यूज करती है ग में भी
आप देख सकते हो आईपीवी सिस भी यूज होता
है चलो नेक्स्ट अभी बात करते हैं पैकेट
स्ट्रक्चर के बारे में बात करते हैं आपके
पैकेट स्ट्रक्चर के बारे में किस तरीके से
आपका पैट पैकेट देखने को मिलेगा देखो आईपी
ऑर्गेनाइज डाटा इनटू पैकेट्स फॉर
ट्रांसमिशन अक्रॉस नेटवर्क्स एंड ईच पैकेट
कंसिस्ट ऑफ ए हेडर एंड पेलोड आपको पता है
कि जब भी डाटा ट्रैवल होता है वन वन प्लेस
टू अनदर वो पैकेट की फॉर्म में ट्रैवल
किया जाता है है तो उसकी एक स्ट्रक्चर्स
होती है जो आपके सामने है ठीक है उसके
अंदर क्या है पैकेट के अंदर दो इंफॉर्मेशन
होती है एक तो एक्चुअल डाटा होता है जिसको
हम पेलोड बोलते हैं दूसरा क्या होता है
हेडर इंफॉर्मेशन तो दिस इज द हेडर अभी हम
बात कर रहे हैं आईपीवी फॉर हेडर की बात कर
रहे हैं यहां पर हम क्योंकि यही हमारे लिए
सबसे मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट है अभी के लिए तो
आईपीबी जो फॉर हेडर है उसके अंदर
क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन होती है ड्यूरिंग द
ट्रेवलिंग जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा था हेडर
के अंदर मेटा इंफॉर्मेशन ये सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन एक हेडर के अंदर होती है इसको
मैं एक्सप्लेन करूंगा द हेड कंटेंस
एसेंशियल इंफॉर्मेशन इंक्लूडिंग द सोर्स
एंड डेस्टिनेशन आईपी एड्रेस वर्जन नंबर
टीटीएल वैल्यू एंड प्रोटोकॉल टाइप यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपके एक पैकेट के अंदर होती है
जब वह ट्रेवल करता है वन मशीन टू अनदर
मशीन मेरा क्या मतलब है यह देखिए एक यहां
पर पॉइंट था मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन करना
चाहता था पैकेट वाला बट ओके ओके यहां पर
नहीं है चलो तो यह है वो पैकेट अभी इसके
बारे में थोड़ डिटेल्स में जानते पैकेट के
बारे में देखिए जो सबसे पहला आपको देखने
को मिलेगा वर्जन बिट्स फोर बिट्स इसका
मतलब क्या होता है इट इंडिकेट्स द वर्जन
ऑफ द आईपी प्रोटोकॉल बीइंग विजड मतलब क्या
है कि इससे आपको पता चलता है
कि कौन सा आईपी वर्जन यूज हो रहा है
आईपीवी सि या आईपीवी फ ओके इट रिप्रेजेंट
द वर्जन ऑफ योर आईपी एड्रेस ओके आईपीवी सि
का ये हेडर है या आईपीवी फो के लिए ओके
यहां पर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिलती है
जो सेकंड इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी
यह आपकी हेडर लेंथ ये इसकी फोर बीट में
देखने को मिलेगी स्पेसिफाई द लेंथ ऑफ द
हेडर हेडर मैं बताया आपको यह सारा एक हेडर
है तो इस हेडर की लेंथ क्या है पूरी जो भी
इंफॉर्मेशन है उसकी कितनी कि क्या लेंथ है
उसको बाइट में इंडिकेट करता है द मिनिमम
वैल्यू इज फाइव इंडिकेटिंग ए 20 बाइट हेडर
एंड मैक्सिमम इज 15 इंडिकेटिंग ए 16 बाइट
हेडर्स ओके मिनिमम फाइव होती है जो बाय
डिफॉल्ट आपको देखने को मिलेगी मिलेगी 20
बाइट 20 बाइट्स का हेडर और दूसरा क्या
मैक्सिमम जो हो सकती है ये 15 तक जा सकती
है मतलब 60 बाइट्स हेडर हो सकता है ओके
नाउ थर्ड जो चीज आती है आपकी वो आपकी टाइप
ऑफ सर्विस बेसिकली आपका क्या है टाइप ऑफ
सर्विस ओरिजनली डिजाइंड फॉर
स्पेसिफाइड इंक्लूड्स फील्ड सच एज
डिफरेंशिएबल कोड पॉइंट
डीएससीपी या एक्सप्लिसिट कंजक्शन
नोटिफिकेशन ई एन टू मैनेज पैकेट
प्रायोरिटी एंड कंजंक्शन कंट्रोल बेसिकली
क्या है कि यहां पर हमें अगर किसी पैकेट
को ज्यादा प्रायोरिटी देनी है नेटवर्क के
ऊपर कि नहीं ये इसकी सबसे ज्यादा
प्रायोरिटी है सबसे पहले यही पैकेट ट्रेवल
करेगा तो वो उसके रिलेटेड जो वैल्यू है वो
सेट की जाती है यहां पर टाइप ऑफ सर्विस के
अंदर ए बिट्स के अंदर जो नेक्स्ट है आपका
टोटल लेंथ इसके ऊपर चलते हैं कि इट
रिप्रेजेंट्स द टोटल साइज ऑफ द आईपी
पैकेट्स इट रिप्रेजेंट्स द टोटल साइज ऑफ द
आईपी पैकेट्स इंक्लूडिंग बोथ द हेडर एंड द
पेलोड इसके अंदर आपकी दो पूरी इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलती है जो आपका हेडर प्लस म पेलोड मतलब
डाटा है उसकी टोटल लेंथ क्या है किस साइज
का ये पैकेट है उसकी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको इसके
अंदर देखने को मिलेगी तो मे भी जो फर्स्ट
लाइन है आपको क्लियर हो गई होगी कि वर्जन
से आपको इंफॉर्मेशन मिलती है कि कौन सा
आईपी वर्जन यूज हो रहा है आईपीवी फ आईपीवी
सिक्स सेकंड हेडर लेंथ से आपको पता चलती
है कि आपके हेडर की क्या लेंथ है नंबर
थर्ड टाइप ऑफ सर्विस में आता है क्यूस
क्वालिटी ऑफ सर्विस मतलब अगर आपको किसी
पैकेट को हाई प्रायोरिटी पैकेट बनाना है
तो वह आपको आपको यहां पर वैल्यू सेट करनी
होगी बट यू कांट डू इट अगर आपको नेटवर्क
की नॉलेज नहीं है तो नेटवर्क इंजीनियर का
काम है ये ओके दूसरा जो टोटल लेंथ है टोटल
लेंथ में आपको देखने को मिलेगी क्या जो
आपकी हेडर की लेंथ है प्लस में एक पेलोड
होगा ये डटा ये रहा देखो यहां तक आपका
क्या है हेडर है प्लस में डाटा है तो इसकी
टोटल लेंथ क्या टोटल साइज क्या है वो आपको
देखने को मिलेगा तो आई होप द फर्स्ट लाइन
इज क्लियर
एवरीवन 20 लाइन क्लियर तो इसलिए इसका टोटल
साइज क्या है 32 बिट देखो 16 बिट 4 4 8 8
16 और ये 16 16 कितना हो गया आपका 32
बिट एवरीवन गट क्लियर दिस लाइन
किसी का डाउट है इससे रिलेटेड क्योंकि आप
सच में आपको काम आएगा यह अभी सच में काम
आएगा आपको जब आप वायस आर के थ्रू ट्रैफिक
एनालिसिस करते हो तो तब आपको सच में काम
आएगा
यह यहां पर आपके लिए मैं कुछ भी एक्स्ट्रा
नहीं है आपका बिल्कुल पार्ट ऑफ सिलेबस है
चलो अभी बात करते हैं आइडेंटिफिकेशन की
बात करते हैं यूज्ड फॉर रिअसेंबलिंग
फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट्स रिअसेंबलिंग
फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट ईच फ्रेगमेंट ऑफ ए
पैकेट इज असाइन द सेम आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वैल्यू फॉर एग्जांपल अगर कोई भी पैकेट
ट्रेवल किया जा रहा है अब उस डाटा का साइज
क्या ज्यादा है तो उसको हम क्या करते हैं
सेगमेंट्स में कन्वर्ट करते हैं ठीक है तो
उनको एक चंक्स ऑफ बाइट में कन्वर्ट करके
भेजेंगे चंक्स ऑफ डाटा तो उन चंक्स को हम
क्या करते हैं अलग-अलग से इंफॉर्मेशन पास
होगी एक साथ तो सारे डाटा पास होगा नहीं
तो जब हम फ्रेगमेंटेड डाटा भेजते हैं तो
उस परे क्या है कि दोन हर एक पैकेट का जब
जिस पैकेट को डेटा को फ्रेगमेंट किया है
हर एक का क्या है ये वैल्यू सेम मिलेगी सो
दैट कि ये मैच किया जा सके कि ओके ये इसी
डाटा का पार्ट है ओके रिअसेंबल करते वक्त
तो ये वैल्यू क्या है आपको देखने को मिलती
है ड्यूरिंग फ्रेगमेंटेशन आइडेंटिफिकेशन
16 बिट वैल्यू होती है नेक्स्ट अभी चलते
हैं हम फ्लैग्स के बारे में यहां पर जीरो
डीएफ एमएफ ये क्या होते हैं देखो इट
इंक्लूड्स थ्री फ्लैग्स रिलेटेड टू द
पैकेट
फ्रेगमेंटेशन व्हेन पैकेट फ्रेगमेंटेशन इज
बीइंग परफॉर्म्ड अब जब पैकेट फ्रेगमेंटेशन
परफॉर्म किया जाता है तो य तीन ये वैल्यू
सेट होने मिलेंगी आपको जो फर्स्ट वाली जो
बिट है आपकी हमेशा जीरो ही मिलेगी मतलब ये
रिजर्व की गई है फर्द अगर कोई कुछ भी यूज
करना हो तो अभी इसको मतलब रिजर्व करके रखा
हुआ है नेक्स्ट डीएफ और एमएफ से हमें मतलब
है डीएफ का मतलब है डोंट फ्रेगमेंट्स मतलब
बिट्स वन इफ सेट टू वन अगर इसको वन कर
दिया जाए आपको वन देखेंगे देखने को मिलेगी
तो इट इंडिकेट दैट पैकेट शुड नॉट बी
फ्रेगमेंटेड मतलब जब आपको डाटा रिसीव होता
है जब ये पैकेट मिलता है यूजर्स के एंड प
जो रिसिपिएंट होता है जो रिसीवर होता है
अगर ये डीएफ वैल्यू सेट मिलती है आपको वन
मिलती है इसका मतलब क्या है कि ये अकेला
पैकेट है फ्रैग टेड पैकेट नहीं है मतलब
इसके बाद कोई भी इस इसका रिलेटेड पैकेट
नहीं आ रहा मतलब फ्रेगमेंट नहीं किया हुआ
मोर फ्रेगरेंट एमएफ बिट अगर इसको सेट किया
हुआ है अगर इसको वन इसकी वैल्यू आपको वन
देखने को मिलती है तो इट इंडिकेट दैट मोर
फ्रेगमेंट्स फॉलो इन ए फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट
अगर यहां पर आपको वन देखने को मिलता है
मतलब डीएफ क्या मिलेगा जीरो मिलेगा यहां
पर अगर आपको वन देखने को मिलता है इसका
मतलब क्या है कि एक फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट है
इसके बाद जो डाटा आएगा ठीक है तो वो भी
क्या है इसी का पार्ट है अब जब डे
फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट्स है तो उस केस में
आपका आता है फ्रेगमेंट ऑफसेट इसका क्या
मतलब होता है मैं आपको समझाता हूं
फ्रेगमेंट ऑप्शन स्पेसिफाई द पोजीशन ऑफ ए
फ्रेगमेंट इन द ओरिजिनल पैकेट अभी इससे
आपको पता चलेगा देखो पैकेट तो फ्रेगमेंटेड
है तो अब उसकी पोजीशन भी पता क्योंकि मुझे
पैकेट को क्या करना है कि रिअसेंबल करना
है तो मुझे उसी ऑर्डर में रिअसेंबल करता
है जिस ऑर्डर में उसको ट्रांसफर किया गया
था तो वो इसकी हेल्प से असेंबल किया जा
क्योंकि यहां पर जो वैल्यू देखने को
मिलेगी उससे आईडिया मिलेगा कि ओके कि ओके
य ये पैकेट इसके बाद यह पैकेट इसके बाद यह
पैकेट इसके बाद यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
इससे मिलती है तो आई होप की जो सेकंड लाइन
है आइडेंटिफिकेशन
जीरो डीएफ एमएफ और फ्रेगमेंट ऑफसेट इसका
क्या मतलब है सबको क्लियर होगा ठीक है
एवरीवन गट
क्लियर दिस वन एवरीवन गट क्लियर
स्टिल एनी वन हैव एनी
डाउट
ओके चलो नेक्स्ट पॉइंट पर चलते हम टीटीएल
वैल्यू अब टीटीएल वैल्यू क्या होती है
टाइम टू लीव इट रिप्रेजेंट द मैक्सिमम
नंबर ऑफ होस ए पैकेट कैन ट्रव्स बिफोर
बीइंग डिस्कार्डेड
डिक्रीमेंटेड बाय वन एट ईच होप बेसिकली
अभी टीटीएल वैल्यू क्या होती है इसके ऊपर
मैं आपको एक सिनेरियो से एक उसके बोल क्या
बोलते एग्जांपल के साथ डायग्राम के साथ
नेक्स्ट अपकमिंग क्लास में मैं आपको
एक्सप्लेन करूंगा कि टीटीएल वैल्यू और
टीटीएल वैल्यू एज ए पेंटेस्टर हमारे लिए
बहुत ज्यादा इंपोर्टेंट है ओके क्योंकि
टीटीएल वैल्यू से हमें मिलती है ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन
ओके प्रगमेंट का मतलब क्या है कल्पना सिंह
कि जो डाटा होता है आपका अगर डाटा की लेंथ
ज्यादा है फॉर एग्जांपल जब आप क्या करते
हो कि आपने काली लिनेक्स था काली लिनेक्स
डाउनलोड किया होगा जब आप काली लिनेक्स को
डाउनलोड करोगे तो आप देखोगे क्या वो सारा
का सारा डाटा एक साथ आता है नहीं वो सारा
का सारा डाटा आपका एक साथ कभी नहीं आता
उसको फ्रेगमेंट करके भेजा जाता है आपके
मशीन के पास और आपको आपने देखा होगा कि जो
वो जब पूरी फ फाइल डाउनलोड हो जाती है 2gb
की 4gb की त भी आप उस फाइल को यूज कर सकते
हो तब तक आप उसको यूज नहीं कर सकते ठीक है
तो फ्रेगमेंट्स का मतलब यह है तो जो
टीटीएल है टीटीएल का मतलब क्या है कि टाइम
टू लिव यह हर एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की अलग
वैल्यू होती है जब आप कई कहीं भी पिंग
करते हो तो वहां पर यह काफी इंपोर्टेंट
होती है मतलब होप क्या होते हैं कैसे इसको
यूज किया टेल के ऊपर मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा अपकमिंग क्लास में मे भी नेक्स्ट
क्लास में आपको एक्सप्लेन कर दूं तो डोंट
वरी अभी समझ लिया कि टेल वैल्यू आईपी
पैकेट के अंदर ही जाती है नाउ प्रोटोकॉल्स
की बात करते हैं प्रोटोकॉल्स
अब इसका क्या मतलब है इट
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
द पैकेट मतलब यहां पर वो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को
मिलेगी मतलब नेटवर्क लेयर प हम काम कर रहे
हैं अभी यह डाटा जाएगा किसके ऊपर
एप्लीकेशन लेयर के ऊपर तो जो कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए डाटा है एचटीटीपी के
लिए है या टीसीपी के लिए है सॉरी टीसीपी
यूडी
आईसीएमपी वो सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर
प्रोटोकॉल की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको यहां पर
इसके अंदर देखने को मिलेगी ओके तो प्रोटोल
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको क पर देखने को मिले किस
प्रोटोकॉल्स के लिए डाटा है उसकी
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको प्रोटोकॉल्स के अंदर
देखने को मिलेगी नाउ उसके
बाद हेडर्स चेक सम बच गया तो हेडर चेकस का
मतलब क्या होता है कि आप चेक्स लगाते हो
कि आपका जो एरर डिटेक्ट करने के लिए कि
आपके हेडर्स के अंदर जो भी आपका हेडर है
उसके अंदर कोई एरर तो नहीं है या कोई
करप्टेड इंफॉर्मेशन तो नहीं है जिससे क्या
है कि आपके डाटा को डिलीवर करने में
प्रॉब्लम हो अगर वहां पर कोई भी एरर्स है
तो उसको रिसेंड करने के लिए बोला जाएगा या
वहीं पर उसको डिस्कार्ड कर दिया
जाएगा ओके नाउ सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस ओके दिस
इज द सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस यहां पर आपको
सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस देखने को मिलेगा और
यहां पर आपको डेस्टिनेशन आईपी एड्रेस
मिलेगा ऑप्शंस ऑप्शंस में आप इंफॉर्मेशन
अदर कोई अगर इंफॉर्मेशन
भेजना चाहते हो अपने पैकेट्स के अंदर तो
आप ऑप्शंस के अंदर भेज सकते हो जो जीरो से
40 बाइट्स के जैसे टाइम स्टंप्स हो गया
अदर कोई इंफॉर्मेशन हेडर के थ्रू आप भेजना
चाहते हैं तो आप ऑप्शंस के अंदर ऐड करोगे
तो दिस इज द टोटल आईपी एड ये रहा अब इसका
प्रैक्टिकल डेमो भी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
लेकिन ये देखिए वर्जन के अंदर आपको आईपी
एड्रेस की वर्जन इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी हेडर
लेंथ पूरे हेडर की क्या लेंथ है टाइप ऑफ
सर्विस आपसे रिलेटेड नहीं है बट यहां पर
अगर आपको किसी भी पैकेट को हाई प्रायोरिटी
पैकेट बनाना है तो वो यहां पर वैल्यू सेट
मिलेगी टोटल लेंथ आपके पूरे पैकेट की लेंथ
क्या है आइडेंटिफिकेशन जब आपका पैकेट
फ्रेगमेंटेड है उस केस में आपको दोनों
पैकेट्स का जो सेंटर साइड में जो ड उनका
आइडेंट सभी पैकेट्स के लिए सभी
फ्रेगमेंट्स के लिए सेम वैल्यू देखने को
मिलेगी अगर वो एक ही डाटा के पार्ट होंगे
डीएफ अगर उसको फ्रेगमेंट करना है नहीं
फ्रेगमेंटेड है यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां
पर देखने को मिलेगी फ्रेगमेंट ऑफसेट तभी
आपको देखने को मिलेगा उसकी वैल्यू सेट जब
आपका फ्रेगमेंटेड होगा ना टीटीएल वैल्यू
प्रोटोल कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल के लिए यह डाटा
है चेक्स की वैल्यू सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी एड्रेस यह सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको शायद समझ में आ गई होगी औरस डटा यहां
पर आपका एक्चुअल डटा पास होता है तो नाउ
आई होप क्लियर कि सबको समझ में आ गई आपका
आईपी हेडर किस तरीके से होता उसमें किस
टाइप की इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलती
है एवरीवन गट
क्लियर मेरा नाम मिलेगा एस ए एम एस ए एम
दिस
वन एवरीवन गट
क्लियर चलो एक काम करता हूं अभी के लिए
मैं आपको अभी इसी को दिखा देता हूं आईपी
एड्रेस को तो फॉर एग्जांपल यह रहा अभी के
लिए इसको बंद करता हूं दिस इज माय वायस
आर्क दिस इज माय वाय सार्क ओके
यस अभी मैं इथरनेट यूज कर रहा हूं तो मैं
डबल क्लिक करता
हूं यहां पर दे लॉट ऑफ पैकेट्स ऑलरेडी दे
लॉट ऑफ पैकेट इन द माय मशीन मैं आपको एक
चीज दिखा देता फॉर एग्जांपल मैं किसी भी
पैकेट प चलता हूं जो मैं इसी टीसीपी पैकेट
अनोज मेंट पैकेट है ये था टीसी अभी मैं
स्टॉप कर देता हूं यह रहा स्टॉप किया यह
रहा अभी यहां पर मैं डबल क्लिक किया तो
यहां पर ये देखिए डाटा लिंक लेयर इथरनेट
लेयर इंटरनेट प्रोटोकॉल य टीसीपी टीसीपी
पैक अभी हमने टीसीपी पैकेट के बारे में
नहीं पढ़ा तो आई विल नॉट शो यू कि टीसीपी
पैकेट के बारे में आपको नहीं बताऊंगा कि
टीसीपी पैकेट के अंदर क्या-क्या
इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलती है और
टीसीपी पैकेट किस तरीके से देखने को मिलता
है तो अभी आपको मतलब क्या है आईपी पैकेट
से तो दिस इज योर आईपी एड्रेस देखिए दिस
इज योर आईपी पैकेट देखो मैंने आपको क्या
बताया था सबसे पहले जो इंफॉर्मेशन देखने
को मिलेगी आपको वर्जन स्पेस दिस इज वर्जन
फोर मतलब आईपीवी फर यूज हो रहा है नाउ
हेडर लेंथ जो ये पैकेट है इसकी हेडर लेंथ
कितनी है 20 बाइट्स इसकी लेंथ कितनी है 20
वायर्स ओके उसके बाद आपको मैंने बताया था
यहां पर टाइम ऑफ टाइप ऑफ सर्विस मतलब
क्वालिटी ऑफ सर्विस आपको डिफरेंस सर्विस
फील्ड डीएससीपी या ईसी एन यह देखो अब ये
इंफॉर्मेशन वैसे सेट नहीं है देख य रहा एक
नॉर्मल पैकेट है कोई हाई प्रायोरिटी पैकेट
नहीं है नाउ तो आपको बता थर्ड नंबर दि फो
टोटल लेंथ 40 मतलब जो पैकेट है ये इसकी
टोटल लेंथ क्या है 40 आइडेंटिफिकेशन ये
देखा 0 एक् 249 स ये आइडेंटिफिकेशन नंबर
है ओके नाउ अभी फ्लैग देखोगे आप फ्लैग की
मैं इंफ दे हूं क्लिक करके देखें रिजर्व
बिट हमेशा जीरो रहती है अभी क्या डोंट
फ्रेगमेंट नोट सेट मोर फ्रेगमेंट नोट सेट
क्योंकि एक नॉर्मल कौन सा पैकेट है ये
आपका एक सिन फ्लैग है बेसिकली अब सिन क्या
होता है ए ए सिन क्या होता है मैं सब कुछ
बताऊंगा अभी नहीं अपकमिंग क्लास में उसके
बाद टीटीएल वैल्यू इसकी टीटीएल वैल्यू
क्या है टाइम टू लीव 58 यहां पर
प्रोटोकॉल्स किस प्रोटोकॉल्स का है देखो
प्रोटोकॉल टीसीपी मतलब क्या है कि ये जो
पैकेट्स है किसके लिए है टीसीपी प्रोटोकॉल
के लिए हेडर चेक सम ये इसकी वैल्यू है नाउ
उसके बाद सोर्स एड्रेस सोर्स एड्रेस क्या
है मेरी मशीन का 142.5
67.7 6 एंड दिस इज डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस
192.168 0 अभी ये क्या है सोर्स एड्रेस
मतलब क्या कि ये रिक्वेस्ट मेरे पास आई है
डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस क्या है यह मेरा आईपी
एड्रेस है मतलब मैं यहां पर डेस्टिनेशन
हूं सोर्स यहां पर को है ये 142.5
6776 तो यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन देखिए तो आपको
समझ में आया दिस इज द आईपी एड्रेस दिस इज
द योर आईपी पैकेट दिस इ योर आईपी पैकेट
देख वर्जन हेडर
लेंथ डीएससीपी टोटल लेंथ आइडेंटिफिकेशन
फ्लैग इंफॉर्मेशन टीटीएल वैल्यू
प्रोटोकॉल्स चेक सम सोर्स एड्रेस
डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस यह सारी इंफॉर्मेशन
आपको देखने को मिल रही है अभी और और किसी
पैकेट को बताता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल यह रहा
दे लॉट ऑफ टीसीपी पैकेट दे लॉट ऑफ टीसी प
पैकेट्स एंड फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अभी यूडीपी
को बता देता हूं किसी भी यूडीपी पैकेट को
यह रहा चलो अभी मैं इसको दिखाता हूं डबल
क्लिक किया अभी इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन देखिए
आईपीवी फर वर्जन इसकी डर लेंथ 20 बाइट्स
है यह इसकी नर्मल पैकेट है तो ओके देन दिस
इज द टोटल लेंथ 310 पिछली की टोटल लेंथ
क्या थी 40 अभी यहां पर क्या टोटल लेंथ
क्या 31 अभी यहां पर आइडेंटिफिकेशन में 0
एक्स मतलब जीरो है अभी यहां पर देखो क्या
सेट है फ्लैग्स के
अंदर डोंट फ्रेगमेंट डोंट फ्रेगमेंट मतलब
क्याय फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट नहीं है य वैल्यू
क्या सेट वन ये रहा बाकी नोट सेट है डिटेल
वैल्यू 58 है कौन से प्रोटोकॉल के लिए
यूडीपी प्रोटोकॉल के लिए हेडर चेक समम देन
सोर्स एड्रेस डेस्टिनेशन एडस मतलब मेरी
मशीन के पास आ रही है एवरीवन गट क्लियर
सबको समझ में आ रहा है
भी कि जो मैंने आपको दिखाया इंफॉर्मेशन यह
आपके सामने है अभी देखिए फ्रेम के अंदर
आपको देखोगे यह रहा सील नंबर वन एंड देन
दिस इज द इथरनेट फ्रेम देन दिस लिस्ट ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन तो आपके लिए ज्यादा रिलेवेंट
नहीं है अब इथरनेट के अंदर देखिए टीपी
लिंक मेरे राउटर का एड्रेस है डेस्टिनेशन
सोर्स टीपी लिंक यह उसका मैक एड्रेस है
डेस्टिनेशन में पीसी का मैक एड्रेस है देन
टाइप अभी देखो इससे मुझे पता चल रहा है कि
जो इथरनेट का जो पैकेट है इथरनेट का जो
डाटा है ये किसके लिए है मेरे आईपीवी फो
के लिए इसके अंदर एक और पैकेट सब पैकेट ये
रहा आईपीवी फ तो इसकी इंफॉर्मेशन यहां पर
है तो शायद आई होप की एवरीवन गट क्लियर कि
आईपी एड्रेस की जो आईपी पैकेट है किस
तरीके से देखने को मिलता है वायर्क के
अंदर एवरीवन गट
क्लियर अभी फ्रेगमेंट वाला एग्जांपल मैं
आपको शो करता हूं चलो एक बार इसको मैं
क्लोज करता हूं और अभी के लिए मैं फिर से
इसको रीकैप्चर करूंगा तो अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं ओपन माय मशीन देन मैंने क्या
किया काली लिनेक्स
काली लिनेक्स एंड दे वेरी बिग फाइल मैं
इसको डाउनलोड करूंगा अगर तो बहुत बड़ी
फाइल है ओबवियसली तो अगर मैं एक काम करता
हूं
अभी च वन आई एम गोइंग टू इंस्टॉल एंड एंड
एंड एंड यस यस यस इंस्टलर एंड इंस्टॉल फॉर
एग्जांपल मैं इस इस पर क्लिक करूंगा इसे
क्लिक करने से पहले मैं ट्रैफिक फिर से
कैप्चर करता हूं यह रहा कंटिन्यू विदाउट
सेविंग यस नाउ अभी मैं क्या करता हूं
इसको स्टार्ट कर दिया मैंने अभी ये
डाउनलोड होना स्टार्ट हो गया काली नेक्स
क्या दिखा रहा देखो अभी मैं इसको शो
करूंगा डाउनलोडस के अंदर तो यस दिस द
डाउनलोड नाउ से मिनट तो नाउ वा ट्रैफिक
देखना अभी यह
रहा कंटिन्यू है कंटिन्यू है अभी मैं इसको
क्या स्टॉप कैप्चर कर देता हूं ना अभी मैं
पैकेट को स्टॉप कर देता हूं नाउ माय पैकेट
एंड कैंसल मैंने इसको कैंसल कर दिया अब यह
देखिए यहां पर अगर आप डाटा देखोगे टीसीपी
के थ्रू दे लट ऑफ टा देखो 43 दिस द विंडो
य देखो इस टीसीपी पैकेट को में देखता हूं
चलो डोंट फ्रेगमेंट एंड नाउ
टीसीपी टीसीपी एक्नॉलेजमेंट एप्लीकेशन
डाटा देखिए एप्लीकेशन
डाटा तो अभी भी य भी नोट फ्रेगमेंट है एंड
एप्लीकेशन डाटा 146 15
1566 तो अभी यहां पर क्या फेंटेड अभी शो
नहीं कर रहा मतलब फ्रेगमेंटेड पैकेट होना
चाहिए बट अभी य क्या कि अभी लाइव में सारी
चीजें थोड़ा सा कैप्चर करना हार्ड होता है
इसके लिए मैं अगर आप मैं देखता हूं किस
तरीके से आपको देखने को मिलेगी वैल्यू सेट
तो मैं इसको क्लोज करता हूं अभी के लिए
कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग एंड
पिक फाइल
एंड
सैंपल वा सैंपल दे सैंपल्स आर
अवेलेबल यस व्हाट इज द मीनिंग फॉर द नंबर
प्रोटोकॉल सेन ओके देखिए नंबर का मतलब
क्या है कि जो प्रोटोकॉल्स के अंदर जो
वैल्यू सेट होती है व नंबर्स में सेट होती
है अभी मैं आपको को शो करूं आपके सामने
अगर यह जो नंबर्स की जो वैल्यू है तो एक
[संगीत]
मिनट कहीं पर मैंने इसके लिए एक
इंफॉर्मेशन
थी तो अभी तो हम इसको थोड़ा
सा टिपिकल है तो फ्रेगमेंट पैकेट होगा तो
वहां पर डेफिनेटली आपको सेट मिलेगी वैल्यू
तो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं प्रोटोकॉल की
वैल्यू
देख आयना के द्वारा यह रहा देखो टीसीपी के
लिए आपको क्या देखने को मिले सिक्स यूडीपी
के लिए क्या 17 देखने को मिली थी ऐसे ही
अगर पैकेट
होगा आईसीएम आईसीएमपी तो वन देखने को
मिलेगा आपको ऐसे पुप तो 12 इस तरीके से
आपको आरडीपी होगा 27 देखने को मिलेगा उधर
तो वहां पर क्या टीसीपी है क्या कि वासर
की स्मार्टनेस है तो आपको ये रीडेबल फॉर्म
में दे रहा है बट अदर वाइज जो पैकेट जो
ट्रेवल करेगा उसमें क्या वैल्यू 17 देखने
को मिलेगी नंबर्स में वैल्यू देखने को
मिलेगी ओके
क्लियर तो आई होप दिस वाज द टॉपिक फॉर द
डे
एंड मे बी एवरीवन
एंजॉयड शायद सबने एंजॉय किया
होगा तो स्टिल किसी का कोई डाउट है तो
मुझसे पूछ सकता है आज की क्लास में इधर ही
एंड करेंगे और तो नेक्स्ट सेशन में हम नया
टॉपिक स्टार्ट करेंगे और जो टीटीएल वैल्यू
है आपकी और ट्रेस रूट से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन है तो मैं
थोड़ा डीप में जाकर आपको बताऊंगा क्योंकि
आपके लिए काफी इंपोर्टेंट है टीटीएल
वैल्यू हमारे लिए काफी इंपोर्टेंट पेन
टेस्टर और नेक्स्ट क्लास में टीसीपी और
यूडीपी के बारे में पढ़ेंगे डिटेल में
जाके टीसीपी पैकेट के बारे में हम पढ़ेंगे
डिटेल्स
में तो टिल नाउ यूव एनी डाउट्स तो यू कैन
आस्क मी नाउ ओके एंड डोंट वरी देखिए अगर
आप लोगों को लगता है कि मैं शायद अगर फिर
भी आप लोगों को स्टिल एनी ट की रिलेटेड
आपको लगता कि सर मैं यह कोर्स क्यों कर
रहा हूं तो देखि अगर आप सोच रहे हो कि सर
मैं यह कोर्स ऑलरेडी सारी इंफॉर्मेशन मुझे
पता है कि मुझे सब पता है कि सर आप जो
पढ़ा रहे हो मुझे बस जबरदस्ती आ रहा हूं
तो आपके लिए एक इससे एडवांस कोर्स है जो
ऑलरेडी बैच थर्ड स्टार्ट हो चुका है होने
वाला है दिसंबर में तो जिसकी अनाउंसमेंट
ऑलरेडी चल चुकी है तो डीसीएसपी
इलेक्ट्रोनिक सर्टिफाइड सिक्योरिटी
प्रोफेशनल जो निते सर ने ऑलरेडी अनाउंस भी
किया है उसका प्राइसिंग भी टैग अवेलेबल है
तो आप क्या कर सकते हो उसको जवाइन कर सकते
हो उसको भी आप क्या कर सकते हो जवाइन कर
सकते हो देखिए अगर डे फोनिक्स पर चलोगे
दिस इज द वे दिस वन र डिप्लोमा इन सिक्स
मंथ डिप्लोमा डीसीएसपी बैच नंबर थर्ड
ऑलरेडी स्टार्ट हो चुका है तो आप इसको भी
कर सकते हो क्योंकि इन फ्यूचर हमारा प्लान
यह है देखिए कि एक कोर्स जो मैं फ्री पढ़ा
रहा हूं यह एक बेसिक फंडामेंटल कोर्स है
उसका एडवांस कोर्स यह रहेगा हमारा एसीएसपी
और इनके बेस पर एक ऐसा सर्टिफिकेशन आएगा
जो इंडस्ट्री आपका एक्सेप्ट करेगी अभी भी
एक्सेप्ट करते है और और ज्यादा हाई डिमांड
पर एक्सेप्ट
करेगी जो आपका एक रेड टीमिंग सर्टिफिकेट
होगा जो इनका कॉमिनेशन होगा जिसका कोई
सिलेबस दोनों है आपका डीसीएसपी वाला
सिलेबस प्लस में आपका डीसी जीएसपी
प्रैक्टिकल वाला सिलेबस है दोनों को
कंबाइन करके उसका एक एग्जाम डिजाइन किया
जाएगा उसका एग्जाम मार्केट में लेकर आया
जाएगा वो डायरेक्ट क्या है आप मास्टर
कहलाओगे मतलब आप र टीमिंग प्रोफेशनल
सर्टिफिकेट आपको चाहिए तो इन नियर फ्यूचर
में डिफ आप लोगों के लिए प्लान कर रही है
उसका सिलेबस क्राइटेरिया क्या रहेगा
सिलेबस क्या रहेगा किस टाइप का
सर्टिफिकेशन होगा वो इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
जल्दी आपको देखने को मिलेगी और नाउ ऑलरेडी
डीसीएसपी का थर्ड बैच स्टार्ट हो चुका है
आप व भी जवाइन कर सकते हो स्टिल अब आप कोई
भी क्वेश्चन मुझसे पूछ सकते हो तो आपके
लिए मोस्ट वेलकम
मोद मैंने आपको शायद बताया ना आईपी एड्रेस
में आपको गो थ्रू फिर भी कर देता हूं बता
देता हूं चलो नहीं आया देखो आईपी एड्रेस
में जो आपको इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल रही
है आपको आईपी एड्रेस से रिलेटेड
इंफॉर्मेशन मिलेगी आईपी पैकेट के अंदर कि
कौन सा आईपी एड्रेस आईपी का पैकेट है ये
दूसरा हेडर इस जो यह कंप्लीट जो हेडर है
इस पैकेट का उसकी लेंथ क्या है टाइप ऑफ
सर्विस आपसे रिलेटेड नहीं है क्योंकि आपको
इससे जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि ये मतलब अगर
सर्विस जो भी पैकेट्स है उसको हाई
प्रायोरिटी पैकेट सेट करना है तो उस केस
में वैल्यू यहां पर सेट की जाती है टोटल
लेंथ पूरे पैकेट की वैल्यू क्या है आपको
बताया था मैंने एक बार 40 में देखने को मि
एक बार 310 देखने को मिली थी
आइडेंटिफिकेशन आपको तब एक आइडेंटिफिकेशन
वैल्यू रहती है जो आपके क्या है कि जो
डाटा है कि सेंडर साइड और साइड वो दोनों
सेम होने चाहिए तभी आपको पता चलेगा कि ये
पैकेट सेम है अगर आपका पैकेट फ्रेगमेंटेड
है या फ्रेगमेंटेड नहीं है वो वैल्यू यहां
पर सेट की जाती है फ्रेगमेंटेड ऑफसेट जो
वैल्यू सेट होती है अगर पैकेट फ्रेगमेंटेड
है तो काफी हेल्पफुल होती है आपके पैकेट
को रिअसेंबल करने में टीटीएल वैल्यू आपकी
होती है नंबर ऑफ हॉप्स कितने ट्रेवल किए
किए हैं क्योंकि जब भी आपकी कोई भी
रिक्वेस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल आपने पिन किया
google.com जैसे ही आपने पिन किया तो सबसे
पहले रिक्वेस्ट जाएगी आपके राउटर के पास
तो उसकी एक टीएल वैल्यू होती है टाइम टू
लीव बेसिकली क्या होता है जैसे ही व पहले
राउटर पे जाएगी तो उसके जो वैल्यू होती है
उसके मैक्सिमम वैल्यू 255 हो सकती है
लेकिन उस पर जाएगी तो उसकी वैल्यू डिक्रीज
हो जाएगी हर एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की एक
वैल्यू डिफाइन होती है मतलब क्या है कि
डेजिग्नेशन तक पहुंचने उसने कितने राउटर्स
लिए कितना होप उसने कैरी किया तो वो सारी
वैल्यू इंफॉर्मेशन य देखने को मिलती है
इससे डिटेल इंफॉर्मेशन अपकमिंग क्लास में
पढ़ेंगे प्रोटोकॉल्स में आपको इंफॉर्मेशन
मिलेगी जो डाटा पैकेट्स है जो पैकेट
ट्रेवल कर रहा है ये किस प्रोटोकॉल्स का
पैकेट टीसीपी का है या यूडीपी का है या
अदर इंफॉर्मेशन आपको देखने को मिलेगी हेडर
चेक्सम्स एरर कंट्रोल इन सब के लिए हेडर्स
में कोई एरर तो नहीं है सोर्स आईपी एड्रेस
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी एड्रेस
ओके ओके एवरीवन गट
क्लियर एक्चुअल यूज है हेडर टेमस का आपके
हेडर्स के अंदर कोई एरर तो नहीं
है सकी वजह से क्या है कि आगे जाकर आपका
हेडर मतलब की ड्रॉप तो नहीं म अगर उसम कोई
भी एरर होगी तो उसको क्या किया वही पर
ड्रॉप कर दिया जाएगा आपके इस पैकेट को और
फिर से रिसेंड करने के लिए बोला
जाएगा ना और और कुछ पूछिए किसी का कोई
सवाल मे बी एवरीवन एंजॉय द
सेशन बट आई एम वेरी
डिसपे दे टोटल ओनली 50 स्टूडेंट्स नोट
मतलब कि 50 स्टूडेंट्स में नहीं
है यहां पर स्टूडेंट्स को वहां पर मजा आता
है कि जैसे कि जिसी की लाइव क्लास में
क्या चल रहा है डायरेक्टली बता दिया कि
ओके वी आर आज हमने वाईफाई हैक कर लिया है
उसपे थंबनेल्स मिलेगा कि हमने मोबाइल हैक
कर लिया लेकिन वो क्या है कि एक प्री
डिफाइंड एप्लीकेशंस को लेंगे वल्नरेबल
एप्लीकेशंस को दिखाएंगे लेकिन थंबनेल्स
ऐसे लगाएंगे वह हमने हैक कर दिया ओके तो
वहां पर क्या है कि ज्यादा
वीडि भी देखने को मिलती है और शायद आप
लोगों को उधर इंटरेस्ट मिलता है क्वालिटी
में आपको इंटरेस्ट नहीं देता आपको इस टाइप
की चीजें चाहिए जैसे बहुत सारे चैनल्स है
रिसेंटली मैं अभी एक किसी के मैंने ऐसे एक
चैनल देखा था जिसके ओनली चैनल 1.2 की है
उसकी सब्सक्राइबर रेट और उसके कमेंट्स में
देखूंगा तो उसके कमेंट्स 120 प्लस कमेंट्स
है सर यू आर द ग्रेट टीचर यू आर द सोन सो
यह वो कि आपसे अच्छा कोई पढ़ा नहीं सकता
और यह वो है मैं टीचर तो है बट उससे बेटर
तो हमारी बग बाउंट क्लास में डिलीवर किया
गया है उसके बारे में उससे बेटर
एक्सप्लेनेशन उसके बेटर वे से लेकिन क्या
कि हमारी बटी क्लास की भीड़ की बजाय उधर
भीड़ है जहां पर उसकी सब्सक्राइबर 1.2 है
और पर हेड विदन वन डे उसका 1.4 1.6 या 1.8
या 2 के 4 के तक जा रहा है जो व्यू रेट
ओनली वन डे या विदन 15 वर्स या ट्स तो
शायद यह है लोग यहां पर आप लोगों को
इंटरेस्ट आता है क्वालिटी कंटेंट क्योंकि
फंडामेंटल में किसी का इंटरेस्ट नहीं है
डायरेक्ट टूल रन करो उसके बाद क्या होंगे
वह किसी एक ऐसे ऑफिस में बैठे होंगे जहां
पर 10 टू 15000 की सैलरी होगी बस वहीं पर
पूरी लाइफ स्पेंड कर देंगे उनको आगे बढ़ने
में प्रॉब्लम होती है क्योंकि वहां पर जब
आपको फेस करने को मिलेगा वो ओके आपको ये
भी नहीं पता आपको ये नहीं पता ये नहीं पता
क्योंकि आपने पूरी लाइफ टाइम एक टूल्स पे
काम किया होगा ओनली लाइ टूल के डिपेंडेंट
हो लेकिन आपको ये नहीं पता टूल्स की
वर्किंग कैपेबिलिटी क्या है कैसे काम करता
है किस प्रोटोकॉल्स के बेस पे काम करता है
तो आपको खुद से अगर खुद की टेक्निक्स
बनानी हो तो वो नहीं आपकी बनानी आती होगी
तो वहां से आप यही चीज सीखते
हो तो ओके किसी कोई डाउट है नेक्स्ट वन
मिनट अदर वाइज आपको बताया डाउट
कैसे पूछ सकते हो मेरी क्लास
में सिंपली आफ्टर क्लास आपको क्या करना
है मैसेज कमेंट बॉक्स में अपना डाउट पुट
इन करना विद योर
नेम और आप लोगों सच में बहुत बेनिफिट होने
वाला है
क्योंकि इस कोर्स के बाद आपको एडवांस
कोर्स करना पड़ेगा क्योंकि यह कोर्स एक
बेस कोर्स है मैं आपको फ्री में हमेशा
बैचे चलेंगे इसके मैं फ्री में डिलीवर कर
रहा हूं समझ रहे हो उसके बाद एक एडवांस
कोर्स है ऑलरेडी चल रहा है फोर्थ बैच भी
आएगा तो आपकी तैयारी फोर्थ बैच के लिए भी
हो रही है अगर आप ऑलरेडी यह सब जानते हो
तो आप थर्ड बैच में एंट्री कर सकते हो अभी
तक अभी भी कर सकते हो सीट्स आर
अवेलेबल ओके तो आप अभी भी एंट्री कर सकते
हो डीसीएसपी अदर वाइज आप नेक्स्ट बैच में
भी कर सकते हो अगर जिसको बिल्कुल जीरो से
अभी इसमें आया तो जीरो से उसमें भी बताया
जाता
है ठीक है तो यह क्या है कि एक आपके एक और
एडवांस जो मास्टर सर्टिफिकेशन है उसकी
तैयारी चल रही है आपकी में जिसके लिए आपको
पा आपसे एक भी रुपया नहीं लिया जा रहा एक
भी
रुपए नहीं इसका कोई सर्टिफिकेट नहीं
मिलेगा
मैं उनका मैं अभी कुछ नहीं बोलूंगा इस पर
अखिलेश बट आई रिकमेंड
नो
बिकॉज एक टाइम था जब वैल्यू थी बट अब नहीं
है के सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर अननेसेसरी
लॉन्ग नहीं बनाते सेशन को फिर भी आपका कोई
डाउट्स है तो यू कैन आस्क मी इन द कमेंट
सेक्शन डेफिनेटली डाउट बोर्ड्स पे आपका
डाउट्स रहेगा और आई विल
गाइड स्टल अगर कोई भी डाउट है तो
आपका टेक्निकल महास दिस इज द वे टू बिकम
एन
एक्सपर्ट मैंने आप लोगों की उंगली पकड़ी
और आपको ऐसी जगह पर लेकर जाकर छोडूंगा
जहां पर आपको शायद गाइड करने की जरूरत
नहीं होगी
आपके पास स्किल्स होंगी ट्स माय
गारंटी इसके बाद जो नेक्स्ट में नेक्स्ट
भी जो फिर एक एडवांस वर्जन ऑलरेडी इन इन
प्रोग्रेस और भी थोड़ा एडवांस लेकर जाएंगे
तो वह आप और जवाइन करोगे तो यू आर
डेफिनेटली एक्सपर्ट इन मेनी
फील्ड्स बस आपको रिवीजन करना है उसके बेस
पर आपको तैयारी करनी है क्योंकि यहां पर
सारे डाउट्स आपके क्लियर हो बेसिक टू
एडवांस आपके पास टैक्टिक्स होंगे आपके पास
कोई भी सीटीएफ मिलेगा तो उसको सॉल्व कर
पाओगे अभी आपको सोचना पड़ता
होगा राजीव अभी आप यह देख लीजिए यहां से
आप पेन टेस्टिंग का पूरा जो
ओवरऑल क्राइटेरिया वो कवर कीजिए उसके
बाद आप डीप अगर ओनली वेब पन टेस्टिंग प
फोकस करना चाह रहे हो जैसे डीप आपको थोड़ा
सा वेब एप्लीकेशन की वलने बिलिटी को फाइंड
आउट करना तो यू कैन गो फॉर बग बाउंडी
सीरीज आपको पढ़ने की जरूरत
है ग्लिच आई डों नो की
हाउ तो आपको अभी य सीरीज देखनी चाहिए बग
बाउंट इसके बाद देख लीजिए दिस कोर्स विल
बी ्र टू फोर मंथ
लंग कंपलीटली आपको एक डिटेल कोर्स है बहुत
कुछ आपको सीखने को
मिलेगा क्योंकि यह आप आपके लिए बहुत मायने
रखेगा इन फ्यूचर सच में क्योंकि
इंडस्ट्रियल रिक्वायरमेंट के साब से
डिजाइंड कोर्स है
जो मैंने डिजाइन किया
है कौन सी मशीन आपकी राजीव
थैंक यू
कोडम मैक एर
एव तो वर्चुअल बॉक्स चलाओ वर्चुअल बॉक्स
मैक पे बहुत अच्छे से चलता है पहले मेरे
पास मैकबुक था तो एव तो नहीं था
बट वर्चुअल बॉक्स बहुत अच्छे से चलता है
और काली नेक्स टूल्स स्पोर्ट करेगा ही
करेगा
फिर और जो ट्रबल शूटिंग एरर्स आती है तो
उनको आप गल कीजिए तो आप पहले ऐसे
स्टूडेंट्स या व्यक्ति नहीं होगी जिसको वो
एरर आई होगी दे लॉट ऑफ इन द
कंट्री ओवरव्यू देखने के लिए तो आप एक बार
जाइए इस वीडियो पर जाइए दिस
वन एंड एंड एंड यह
रहा वेर माय सीरीज प्लेलिस्ट गो टू
प्लेलिस्ट एंड इस इसके सिलेबस में क्याक
है तो यू
कैन यह रहा डीसीएसपी प्रैक्टिकल लाइफ फी
ट्रेनिंग अनाउंसमेंट सेक्शन में यू कैन सी
इट यहां पर सब कुछ डिटेल्स में बताया गया
कोर्स में क्याक होने वाला
है डे वन से
पहले तो सेशन को एंड
करें एट टाइम्स वन कीजिए राजीव और शायद
इसको कंटिन्यू करना चाहिए पहले आप
एट टाइम एक चीज पर फोकस कीजिए अगर फिर भी
आपके पास ज्यादा टाइम आपको सॉरी अगर आपको
टाइम मिल रहा है तो आप दोनों पर फोकस कर
सकते हो फिर आपको काम
आएगा टास्क कभी नहीं है टास्क में जरूर
दूंगा थोड़ा सा बेसिक फंडामेंटल कवर कीजिए
आपको टास्क डेफिनेटली मिलेंगे आपको लब्स
मिलेंगे सॉल्व करने के लिए भर भर के मैं
आपको मैं करवाऊंगी उसके बाद में उसका सेम
कॉपी आपको प्रोवाइड भी कर दूंगा तो आपको
डेफिनेटली आपको प्रैक्टिस करने के लिए
चीजें प्रोवाइड की जाएंगी बट अभी के लिए
आप बेसिक कवर कीजिए उस बेसिक प अगर आपको
कोई रिसर्च करनी है अगर आपको ऐसा लगता है
कि कोई अगर आपसे उससे रिलेटेड कोई पूछे इन
फ्यूचर में एज इंटरव्यू या कहीं से भी कि
यह चीज होती क्या है इवन आपका फ्रेंड ही
क्यों ना हो तो आपको उस परे कैसे
एक्सप्लेन करना है कैसे जवाब देना है मेरी
वीडियो प्लस में थोड़ा सा गगल कीजिए तो
आपको एक बेटर आंसर मिल जाएगा और जजे नोट्स
उसको रखिए फिर
एडवांस कोर्स है ऑलरेडी डीसीएसपी है और
उसके बाद और भी एडवांस है एडवांस तो जैसे
कि एड पन टेस्टिंग भी है ब्लैक हैट कोर्स
एक प्रकार
से उसको मैं ही पढ़ाता
हूं और नेक्स्ट मंथ उसका बैच टू स्टार्ट
होगा तो बहुत एडवांस उसमें तो बहुत कुछ है
भर भर के
यू कांट
इमेजिन ओके सेशन को एंड करते हैं बाय बाय
टेक केयर गुड नाइट और फिर भी स्टिल एनी
डाउट तो आस्क मी इन कमेंट सेक्शन बाय बाय
टेक केयर एंड गुड नाइट